It takes like 30 seconds for it to register going live, so I would say hi to VodReeflings or VodLings.
Hi!
I accidentally...
Wait, what?
I don't know what's happening. It's like...
Are you selecting the wrong thing?
It's not letting me type in my own chat!
You've done it now.
Am I banned from my own chat?
Hold on, let me go look at your chat as well.
I'm sorry, but you're being graduated live.
I'm graduated live!
This is... we're doing it, imagine? Imagine a company did that?
They're just like, hey, I'm gonna have you collab with everybody and then like a manager and like a P&G shows up and they're like...
I'm sh... that must...
Sorry, you're gone.
I've seen it. That has to have happened behind the scenes.
And like, the VTuber's just been too polite to say anything about what happened.
I got signed up on my YouTube channel! I can't fucking comment on your stream!
What?!
Wait, I was like...
Oh!
I got signed up on my YouTube channel! I can't pin my fucking...
Is that what happened? Is that you got signed up on my YouTube?
Uh, hold on a minute.
What just happened?
It's a purge of violour. Hold on.
The second...
The second... I can't just hit the...
I can't...
Sorry.
The second account has been hit!
I was like... I was just trying to say it.
This is like a type of joke to her making an all day of days traffic?!
No! It's fine! She's fine! She started it!
I woke up, and the first thing she sends me is a freaking Skippity 9-11 meme!
I'm like, fuck me! What am I supposed to do with that?!
Ha ha ha!
Right. Okay.
Wait.
Hold on. I won't...
I'm still! It says error try again!
Okay, hold on. Hold on. I'm getting your YouTube password!
How?
I'm getting your YouTube password!
Sorry, Ken!
I can't talk in my own chat!
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm retrying...
No! Don't add me! Yeah! I've not even put down my fucking stream name yet!
I've not put down my stream name yet!
So...
Am I live?
I'm live!
Yeah, you're live! I'm also live!
Wait, I'm getting your YouTube password.
I'm hacking into the mainframe!
I can't even message on your channel!
No, no, no. It's because we've been signed up.
YouTube does this random thing as well.
Wait, how am I still streaming?
No, so you can be signed out on OBS that still let you in, if that makes sense?
Oh, okay.
But it's showing that I'm not signed out. I still have my thingy.
I mean...
What's happening?! Why can't I type in my chat?!
This is like an OBS type in your chat or on YouTube type in your chat?
YouTube type in my chat.
Right. You've been signed out as well. You just need to refresh.
Okay, I give up. Sorry, guys. I cannot say hi.
No, no, no! She can't! I'm getting the password! I'm hacking the mainframe!
Hold on!
I was in a Left 4 Dead 2 DLC. I was talking about Vtube Studio, by the way, guys. Not that.
Okay, this one is huge.
How do I join your game?
For the love of God, do not show this on stream.
For the live of...
Oh, wait. I'm going to spoiler it. There you go. Don't fucking show that on stream.
That's your password.
And then I'm deleting it once you're in.
You're now a standard moderator. I'm not even signed in!
I said I'm a standard moderator in your chat when I'm not signed in.
I can't believe it.
I've been up...
Signed out. Sinking is passed.
Good morning, Reflings and Harum. How's it going?
I don't know how we could have started any worse.
But we got there.
I'm in. Right, I'm in. I can chat.
Taste. Right, taste.
Wait, it still says error?
Oh, my God. Wait, did YouTube just shit the bed? YouTube...
I think YouTube might have just...
It's just really...
Hey, I just got recommended a clip.
Wait, what does that mean?
Clip?
No, clip. I was recommended a clip.
Oh, they're tipping me. Chat is actually broken.
They broke...
On stream snipe fucking day.
Why, YouTube? Why do you...
I can't start chatting over tips.
Oh, my God.
Everybody sends a scent of a tip.
Okay, so chat's busted.
Don't worry, Reflings and Harum, if you're typing,
we are now aware that chat's busted.
Hold on, let me open up Marshmallows.
I'm sure it's just filled with Reflings being like,
Oh, I can't do it.
Oh, it's out on you.
Mommy, I think YouTube chat is broken.
I can't chat or see it updating.
YouTube chat is completely broken.
I guess you're just going to have to stream snipe us
so we can talk then.
You need to give a live commentary on the stream in-game, okay?
I'm so bummed right now.
Why would it break today?
That's so...
Yeah, because the last one is people just saying hi.
Yeah, it broke like right before we...
I'm going to...
Hold on, is it...
Let me just turn this into a Zatsu.
Let me look on Twitter.
You want to do an interrogation?
We get Reflings and Harum in on stream
when we interrogate them to prove their love.
We make references to streams
and if they haven't watched them, they get kicked out.
Who's that you're?
Wait, it's called a fakeling.
If you can't watch every millisecond
that of content I produce, you're called a fakeling.
A fakeling?
You're called a harlot derogatory for me.
Derogatory!
Ah, you had it here.
You had it here first, not to hear them spank spank.
I'm just going to tweet.
Did YouTube just break?
I think so.
Did you order that Ethernet cable, by the way?
I did.
I did immediately after.
Right.
The next thing I'm supposed to get you to download
which apparently you don't have, U-Block.
You don't have U-Block?
What is U-Block?
It blocks a lot of piss.
We are stuffed cries.
My TTS is going crazy
because everyone's like, we can't speak.
We bane.
It's okay, Harrow.
It's okay.
You haven't been silenced, guys.
I promise we haven't.
I'm watching another show about a hurricane.
What?
And his chat seems fine.
Wow, this is terrible.
What?
Is it just us?
It's literally just us.
We've been targeted.
What?
They had to nerf or collab.
They knew it was too powerful.
I'm like super upset.
Wait, I'm going to go to somebody.
I'm going to go to an AC stream.
I was bursting in an AC chat.
How's it going?
I know.
Hold on, right?
Both of us in an AC chat.
Hello?
I'm going to open it.
No, it doesn't work.
Hi, Dolph.
Oh, my God.
I can't type in AC's chat either.
She must be like, oh, no.
There's no fairies aren't interested in this game.
And it's like, no, that's not the truth at all.
We're literally that scene in Interstellar.
Murph, come back, Murph.
I'm going to message it right now.
YouTube chat.
YouTube is going to want us.
Husky, thank you for the tip.
Relatively saying, mother, can you hear me?
Thank you for the tip.
Mama, no, thank you for the tip.
Everybody's shouting from the void.
Don't give me money.
Just use Marshmallow as free of charge.
Yeah, use Marshmallow.
I'll look at Marshmallow.
Emmy doesn't have an ad blocker either.
I don't have an ad blocker.
Do you guys enjoy suffering?
How do you watch content?
I just watch it on my TV because I have premium.
I usually watch YouTube on TV.
It's not just you guys.
I checked Kiara's stream from HoloLive in her chat.
It's so broken.
So it's that way.
Oh, my God, it's so hard.
It's a rogatory.
Cheating on VLOR?
Let me see if I'm going to go to Mozumies.
OK.
Hello, is your chat also broken?
Yeah, it is.
It depends how you want to do it.
We could still stream snipe.
It just means we don't know what's going on half the time.
Everybody here.
Mommy, I have no voice and I must thank.
I see Emmy's channel is back up.
Hey, why would you say that?
I don't know why you would say that.
Yeah, fucking cunt.
Yeah, that one.
That one didn't land, chief.
I'm going to be.
Wait.
What?
Is there a count?
Hold on.
Hold the fuck.
Wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
I'm going to have to go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm so sorry.
I have to go for five minutes.
I'll be right back.
I need to delete some shit.
That doesn't make any sense.
Okay, I take.
I'm sorry.
I called you a cunt.
You're amazing.
Oh, we're back.
We're back.
Are we back back?
Are you squiddin' me right now?
We're back.
Give me broad chat back from the Void underscore glow.
I can't have to go back to my own chat
because I've been going to other people's chats.
That's just me and Serani just sitting here in the Void.
Guys.
Oh, thank God.
I'm so sorry.
Thank God.
Just picture me pulling you close to my chest
and just swinging you around by your little feets.
Oh, my God.
That was actually low key.
I don't know why.
That was that was scary.
It's like you guys die for a second for me.
I'm not going to lie.
That that scared me for a good bit.
Um, that doesn't make any sense.
How did Emmys account come back?
Because I think
What?
They didn't even send an email.
I mean, Serani, we're just talking about it.
Oh, oh, this is going to make Emmys so happy.
Oh, we were sacrificed to the YouTube gods
and I believe it.
Wow.
I literally was about to have like a mini panic attack on stream.
That's none of you guys know how parasol shall be fucking are.
I guess I can bring back the fucking.
I don't know why I should have just kept that back on.
All right.
It's all right.
We're playing in reeflings and how do we are fine?
Here, let me let me bring a spoke both up.
Oh.
Okay.
I just.
Never mind.
I can't do that.
Oopsies.
Yeah.
We saw anything.
Emmys us.
She's been she's risen.
She has.
She is the second coming of the messiah.
The one that was promised.
You.
Put the cuttlefish down.
No, I like I like wiggling her around.
I wish I could pop her head off and I can stick her on a skateboard like I did.
Like I did with my head yesterday.
That would be fun.
Wasn't it?
And then we can both just have a little skate park together.
I think that'd be pretty neat.
Don't you think so, mummy?
Oh, yes.
I think so.
Very much so.
That'll be fucking great.
She be I can't believe you came up with that.
That was a really fucking spanking idea.
Yeah, she's helpless.
Oh, mom, I can't do a single thing.
Looks like I just got it, you know.
I'm eating her hair.
It's cotton candy flavored.
She's lollipop hair.
You know, the first time I saw her, Strani's model, I thought she was going to be candy themed.
Her hair is made of fiberglass.
Ow!
I don't think that's so spanking.
I don't know.
I couldn't think of anything.
YouTube probably did a system restore a week ago to every account that Gorban got restored because YouTube looked like crap.
Wait.
I want to screenshot that and send it to Strani.
Did the people?
Dude.
That's just weird fucking timing then.
What spell did I see do?
I'm fucking shaken.
That's so weird.
Look at the message I just sent you.
I am shaking.
Wait.
Hold on.
What?
Sorry.
I can't say this.
I know.
We're going to disappear for a second, guys.
I'm going to...
We'll be right back.
I love you both.
Okay, bye-bye.
Wait, where are you going?
No, wait, where are we going?
I'm just muting.
Oh, you're muting?
Wait, hold on.
Let me mute this.
I was just like, imagine I'm one-sided.
Give me one second and I'm here.
Thank you.
Business.
Business, Business, Business, Business.
Business, Business, Business.
Business.
Memory.
Business, Business, Business, Business.
Professionalism.
Professional.
Business, Business, Business.
Business, Business, Business, Business.
Right.
Speaking of business.
shall we get right into the stream unterbone.
No.
Let's get right.
I
Can only it's weird, but I can only do it in the back of my throat. I can't roll my tongue
Like I could do that
You got an enlarged you feel like Maricely
Is that a thing she's Maricely said it to me
She's like I have an enlarged you feel and I was like I don't wear my fannies big too and she was like no
I'm not talking about that
I
Know strongy, that's a ball of a
Teasing by the way, I'm teasing before anyone says and that was a tease
Sometimes I can come out where joke. Okay, sometimes I can sometimes he's got she's got tea he okay
I can do it easy something same to same eight
Or the uninitiated harem on the uninitiated reflex I
I strongy cuttles have a steam account which you can stream snipe and add me on okay
the addition is
strongy snipes now if you don't have my POV up because you're on a she be side
I'm showing it on screen right now
But it's strongy snipes. So what the agenda nation is and I have pieces of paper if you've never done stream sniping
But with me before I have a piece of paper where I write down who's played with us
And who's not and we work on an honor system where you do not play if you have a chance to play
You do not join until we do the reuse system where we read you again. So the train continues. We continue to train you
So you can add me on this account the truth of the matter the fact of the matter is I have never played left for dead
Two before she be has so we're gonna play some campaign mode
And then I have been heavily heavily heavily recommended to play a game mode
Which is 4v4 zombies versus survivors?
and
So, yes
We're gonna. Oh, I didn't even know that was a game mode
Well, apparently it's the most popular thing and we can get six reflund in here a minute a time
And I've never played this game before I'm killing all of you. Just kidding. Oh, this is gonna be I'm gonna get my ass
Handed to me. This is this is Dom loss. I can't
This goes against my nature
Management you've been suspended
What?
No, it's like could you've been suspended because you're doing the opposite of your war or whatever. Oh, oh
I was like wait did somebody guess no, no, no, no, no, it's like
Pick up their arse about it. I'm like that gear
Let me I forgot to tweet out my stream. So well you get that sorted. I love to eat
What's push the talk? Hello?
Hello, what is my talk fun?
You know, say pop use all of us
Yeah
Use voice communication
I tried I'll I'll catch us in the game anyway, right? So we can only play with
Play campaign place their corporate of campaign online. Am I hosting that? Do you want hype? No?
I don't know. I think you might host it because you all have the bear. Oh wait
I do you have the ethernet cable and yes or no, no, not yet. It won't be here
Better internet than you and I'm happy across the globe
Leave me alone. You also have all the account and stuff. So oh, yeah, dumb ass
Play online with friends
Search for game no create a new campaign. I'm a friend
difficulty
What's that? It's the first time I played the game before anyone starts chance. Right? And
Because I'm putting on expert mode. I should just lie and say this is my first
I
Just want to make sure you're aware of sprays might be smart to make sure that's disabled
Oh, are people gonna do like sprays and they're all just like no not the cod lobby sprays
Wait, you can like custom make your own spring. I didn't even know that
Right a fish server type official dedicated. I assume that's the one that doesn't show my IP
Hmm, please don't come to my house. I come to yours
Friends only game create lobby like this. How do I add strong? My account code strongy snipes
You're suspended
Somebody stop talking about suspensions. I can't handle it. I'm getting nervous. We don't have to use voice chat
No, you're not forced to use voice chat, but you can say hi if you want, right? Don't snipe the slots because she be needs to come in
Right, how'd I get you in?
Well, why don't you just hide your screen for a second and then I can join? Well, I
Don't think I don't like every one
Yeah, but
Did you get that kind of get the chats so I could see both chats? Oh
Oh, I never even thought about that. That's fucking genius. Hold on a minute. Yeah, she's all right. I
Got she is cooking. Let me open up her stream so I can read both channels at the same time
Okay, I got I need a third fucking display, but I don't have enough room. Um, you invited me
Sometimes
There I am
Are you in? Oh, hey, there's a see there's a harem in here. I knew someone would sneak in
Fuck sake, they were quick on it, right? So I need to write down your names now because you are
Ergen so in tip
Not Leviathan
Right and then not Leviathan and then I write down the name
So then on the honor system next time when it comes to people that can join right just start game
I guess
What's my push to talk one? I don't know
I need to change it. They can they just they can hear us delayed
Oh, my bgm is still playing in the background. I turned it on
Get off
While we were talking did I tell you you have a second background music technically
Is the first one the first one I got you came out
Not correct for you
Wait, no, what is it?
Uh, I see after stream if you want
Yeah, I don't know
I got it concepted. It was still based after sonic heroes, but I had whistling in it and it was like no no whistle
Uh, don't do that to me. So then I just completely got it read on to your current one
Uh, because it did not fit you at all
But that was on me because your design wasn't finished yet and I went ahead and ordered the background music
No, okay
I got an achievement if you're reading this achievement gave Newell has successfully what?
I'm a cool dude. Oh my god. Let's grab a break now and get the hell out of here. Yeah, that looks sensitive
Wait, this my sound is way too quiet and keep our heads. We can get out of this
Yeah, how does a talking game test? I don't know. Oh see
All right. Hey, I'm in refland who's like born. Can you hear me?
I can't
Wait, there's no aim down sight in this game. Hello. Oh, I hear you in game
How
No, you can't aim. No. Yeah, it's more source games. You just don't aim down. You just shoot
Me melee is wrong
No, no, this is all wrong. This can't be. Oh, we can hurt each other in game. Oh, yeah
Let's not be shooting each other people
Yeah, let's not be shooting ourselves. That's rude. You're a bald black man, shiny
This is actually the real me underneath. Um
Deep down inside. I'm a
Remind me of my father
Oh, where is melee? I'm going blind
Hey big man
Yeah, what was that?
Wait, is that a refland plot? No, that's in game. I can't find. Yeah, that was in game. I give up
It's push enemies away. Why would it be called push enemies away?
The achievement was for when Gabe Newell put a gnome on an actual rocket
Strati is papa's now I was not expecting the Strati face reveal
Thank you
Diego
John Omni, I thought you were fucking trolling. I'm so sorry. I genuinely thought you're trolling about that anything
You must forgive me melee weapon
Yes, apologies. Oh my god, we're playing Gmod
I made it, but this is it's it's not gmod. It's made in source
Pick up the the crowbar. It's gmod. It goes like like gmod
Or am I being dumb? Well, no, you're not dumb. It's made in the same engine engine
I'm being beat up by my own harlot. Okay, uh
Well, let's get to it first impressions of life or dead too. I'm scared already. Is it too late? Where my gun go?
You either have a pistol or a melee weapon. Oh, you can go like katana much
Yeah, you can grab a katana
Stay together to survive. Okay. I understand
We will be protected up. Wait
Oh
Sorry
Oh my god, they're so fast
Why I thought this was gonna be like a dead island rip page. Oh, no, it's not. They're not slow
They're fucking terrifying
Oh, no, they're doing all the work so
I was gonna watch trying to get attacked by zombies this entire time
Oh my gosh, they have like radio the guys and pistols have unlimited ammo. Okay. Good to know good to know
Oh my gosh
All right, I would not do well as an operative in terms of I would end up like shooting everyone who crosses me
Okay, what is happening? Oh
Wait, wait, wait, what's going on? What does the yellow mean? Sorry? I needed to
I saved the harlot
Get a magazine. There's like different like little mini boss. Oh, they're like zombies of special abilities
Like a smoker like does like poison gas and you have a jockey that rides you and kind of like eats your head
I keep missing I'm sorry. I'm just enjoying myself watching everyone
Hey
This is the beauty of stream snake. I think you've already done the stream snake game before having
I don't think so. Can I jump out the window? Oh
I thought you've played before I didn't play the campaign
Oh, you've no please campaign
Oh, no, I played like a game mode with the girls from you may
Oh
Pain pills
Refling refling heal up with these pain pills
I didn't think I thought there's gonna be a wall and I couldn't jump out. You didn't save her from herself funnily enough
I assume pain pills heal
How has strawdy never played this game? I I am surprised about that. I was sorry. I just show I I just never played
Just one of these games I never played. Oh, pain pills give temporary health. Okay. Yep. Yep
Right, so we'll please
Campaign this is on fire
Oh, it's a spare spares or squares. Oh my gosh
Oh my gosh
Why did it come from the back? That's scrawny would die first
Oh my god
You got grabbed by by something. Oh my god, I don't like it. I don't like it
That was awful
a smoker
Damn really feel strongly about smoker
We hate smokers. We hate vapor. Yeah, they got little tongues that grab you to raise a dead player, right? Uh, sure
Sure, I'll just aim bought it from here. How far do you think these go? Wait, is my body still down there?
Yeah, you're just you're just chilling in a little red outline. I'm just there
What my purse sheeps through
I'm gonna keep that
Boomer has vomited on you. What does that mean?
It's like
Poison you're taking. Yeah, you're taking health damage
I'm not supposed to be doing melee so I don't hurt you guys. I feel like I'm going to be the reason we die like
Uh, probably be me because I died first if anything
She's like
Someone says you're going to respawn in a closet. Oh my god, she you didn't tell
This is who I truly am
Oh
Don't fall off and you baby. Oh my god. No, what's going on?
What is going on?
I have you got chainsaw
That's so straddling
Oh, hey, I'm here. Oh, I'm in a closet. Oh, are you actually no?
That's how you respawn by coming out. I'm coming out. I want the world to know
I have a oh, I thought I had a whole thing. I guess I don't get mommy get mommy. She'd be out before
Is that an English? I'm just gonna shoot randomly
But I think the reeflands are way more
And the here are more better at the game than I mean they seem to have melee weapons, which makes me oh
They get the strap. Oh my god
They come from nowhere
I'm just gonna sit in this elevator. Oh get to the elevator. I'm coming to the shaft
Oh
Okay, okay, this is like black ops one zombies. We have to take the elevator
Her name's Rochelle. She is a fucking chainsaw. Are you guys too scared to talk?
They're shy
Oh, I'm put whoa
Why is my
Are we dead?
Are we interested in an elevator?
Mike doesn't work. That's what they always say
Pride door open to escape
She's the alert the horde
I can send my thoughts at the evil horde for the zombie zombie horde
Shoot my magnum sword sword
I don't
I don't know how many times I'm gonna get notified to
Not shoot my teammate. I cannot see anything. How do we get out of here?
I'm dying of I have adrenaline
Does this have bullets? Where are we going? I'm following them. I'm following them. Can you see them? Yeah? Yeah?
Yeah, they're over here
Oh, yeah
How'd you she be how'd your gun sound?
I couldn't roll my my tongue i'm sorry
That's yeah, that's what it sounds like Lidl Lidli Lidli Lidli
Someone says mid kit
Stream sniper you need a medk ticket
Ah shit managed you close press. Oh my god
What are you doing? What are you doing face for your enemies yeah? No shit
How am I not dying from smoking halation is it over here?
I have no idea.
I got a pipe bomb.
Oh I'll save you.
Oh thanks queen.
Oh my god I can't believe your hotel got overrun by zombies.
I know Wonderland is not looking so good right now.
Wonderland more like zombie land get it cause it smells like zombies.
Fucking laugh.
Is that a med kit?
Give that to me.
Oh ow.
Help.
Pipe bomb.
I got it.
I know all the tires in the morning.
So that was my pipe bomb.
The big bleeping red brick of C4 you couldn't see and walked right into it.
Are you okay?
Close the door once everyone is in.
Okay.
Oh my god we're in Japan.
All the vending machines get that corn juice.
What do you mean we're in Japan?
You guys got vending machines?
Yeah there's vending machines in America.
But there's the most vending machines in Japan.
Yeah like person or maybe just overall.
That's right strongy snipes.
Melee fit yeah I did no melee at all.
I was at more of a pew pew you know.
Coming with a blast.
Okay that so now we're doing the second map so I need to kick out the cur-
Wait hold on hold on this is-
Did I despawn?
No.
Right so we need to kick out the current reflands and add in Merrim and add in the next round right?
This was a round?
That was a round?
I don't know.
Will that work if we invite them or does it restart the whole thing?
I don't know if that is considered.
Round two of the first map.
Okay so this will still keep it.
There's five rounds per campaign.
You can shift people if you like.
Oh no but don't.
It's been nice.
Oh shit that-
Yo he just let-
Oh he just dipped!
Okay if you leave, if you leave is that okay?
We'll do like one round each.
I know it's not long but we're going to play the four v four so you'll get a chance to play.
Yeah I know we'll get more of you guys in.
Yes so then can someone out a great run see ya?
So now there'll be Idol and other reflands can join in.
Yes.
Right everyone heal up.
First thing first.
And the realists.
Right we have Pearly.
Is Alice at the NPC or is-
Rachelle.
Uh Alice is the person's name yeah.
Oh right okay so-
I mean the NPC's name.
Can someone say-
Now it's Peanuts the pig.
Peanuts.
No Peanuts sorry.
Okay there we go.
I've wrote your names down.
Right hi.
I can get a second pistol.
Wait if you streamstape on the body you don't have-
You don't come in with full um-
Do I have dual burritos the fuck?
Here he is.
Okay hydration check.
I've been slurping.
I'm on that cooler grind I don't know about you but-
I'm sipping some lemonade.
Alright I'm ready to rumble.
I'm ready to-
Thank you for your service Harlots.
Are you scared?
Do you guys talk?
Are you too scared to talk?
Alice.
Let's find out.
Hello bitches.
Hello.
They get-
Hi.
It's so intimidating.
Who's more intimidating?
Me or Stevie?
What do you think?
That's a great question.
I think we both have our traits that are-
Intimidating.
Oh they see you!
They see you.
You're more intimidating.
Me?
Yeah.
What?
Why am I more intimidating?
They're just saying that because they're racelings.
This is women in general.
And they're-
Women in gen-
Whoa!
What was that?
A hunter.
Yeah.
Yeah everyone says you.
Jeez!
What did Stevie do to you?
I'm terrifying.
Yeah.
Whoa!
What's that?
It's fat.
Oh.
What the hell just happened to me?
I saved.
I came.
I saw.
I saved.
Get adrenaline.
I praised the law.
I tick.
What's mine?
Then tick some more.
They said-
I had one person that said you.
I think it's because they're your reeflings.
And they may have watched me from time to time.
Wait.
Do harems seem mostly you?
Or do harems seem mostly me?
One of them said me.
And then one of them said you.
Who's more dominant?
Shibi or Azura?
I'd actually say Shibi.
Yeah.
I'd say me for that.
Azura definitely could be Dom when she wants you.
She can turn that on.
But she just doesn't.
Yeah.
Get a pipe bomb.
Fucking hell.
I'm afraid I've got some ancestry that doesn't let me pick up these kind of weapons.
But thank you for the offer.
What?
I'm part Irish.
You're part Irish?
Hi.
My life is a lie?
No.
No, no, no.
So I'm born in Scotland.
Scottish parents.
But then it goes into Ireland.
Ireland because of the famine.
Migrant in Scotland.
It's quite common ancestry.
I think I'm like 10% Irish.
Fuck yeah.
Or like 15.
I'm a lot.
I have to find my ancestry thing.
Oh, you actually did it.
That would be really interesting to look at.
As long as you're looking for your name.
Yeah, because I'm a major mutt.
So I wanted to figure out why.
Oh, you're a mutt?
Oh, that's such a cute way to say it.
Oh, I see so much.
Yeah.
I'm a mongrel.
Are we mongrel?
Oh, we duck.
You're so cute.
Little pupper.
What is that?
A boomer.
Okay.
Okay, boomer.
Whatever you say.
Okay.
Boomer.
That's it.
When am I getting a shabby song cover?
I'm waiting.
I know.
I needed.
I was so strong.
I'm like, I can't do the song cover that I wanted to do.
It's too hard.
So I have to think of something else to do.
It's actually really hard to...
And ironically, before anyone was like, oh, doing a song cover must be easy.
It's actually not.
It's very hard to do it the way you want to do it.
And especially if you don't have any...
Oh, I'm sorry.
What did you do?
I kept shooting.
I killed the little leaper thing, but then I kept shooting the first time.
Oh, wait.
There must be a combination name of harem and weakling.
Pearling.
Hearling.
Harling.
Reefum.
That sounds like a roofing people.
I'm a reef you so...
I'm a reefum this shithead of you.
A reef lot.
Rack.
Unless you want to be picking your teeth up off the floor.
Unless you want to be...
Why do I just randomly have...
Can I throw this?
I thought I would explode.
A spitter.
Huck toa.
Oh, you made a joke yesterday about Huck toa.
It was really good.
I was like, until I get to you, I need to Huck to you.
Huck toa.
Like, you kept going and I was like...
If you don't Huck toa, I don't Huck toa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, damn, what lyrical genius.
Because I was writing short scripts while listening to Sheebie yesterday.
I may or may not popped up on her stream at one point and got a bit incoherent.
But...
Oh, I think that I'm...
You weren't incoherent.
I was doing a Sheepster's Donut on.
Like goals.
I was like implementing her goals because she sent me a screenshot of what she's up with here.
And I was like torturing ASMR and I'm like...
What?
What did I eat?
I just didn't even know what it meant.
Like what it entailed.
So it's having a giggle.
It's having a big giggle about it.
And...
I must protect.
Protect.
Protect and attack.
Adrenaline.
Oh, you have.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool.
Pintas, you might need adrenaline.
What?
Pintas?
Sorry.
I should probably heal myself.
Strony, your robot voice was so funny.
I love when Strony...
I was dying on the toilet laughing because it was just like robotic Scottish noises.
Reloading.
No, I killed the boomer.
We...
Strony...
I love when Strony said it's reefing tape and refilled all over the...
What?
Reloading.
That's how it be.
Strony's close.
Oh my god.
Oh, you startled the witch.
What is that?
It's the witch killer.
Oh, that's awful.
Oh, I don't like that at all.
I was just shooting hands.
I promise, I promise.
I didn't know it was a witch.
I don't know what the witch does.
I honestly don't know what her thing is.
Someone says go hug the witch.
Hmm, I don't know what she does to you.
Someone's crying.
Jockey!
Jockey.
Golf club.
Oh, there's a dude behind us.
Where is he?
I can't shoot him.
If you shoot her, she rushes to you and ends the...
Oh, hold on.
I'm coming.
Easy, easy, easy.
I am going to die.
Got it.
Thank you.
I'm in.
I didn't mean to shoot you.
I'm sorry.
Couch!
Don't shoot.
Well, it actually saves you, but please don't spray me with bills.
Okay, that is a reasonable request.
She gives time.
I like how the adrenaline is...
Looks like an EpiPen.
Because that's what an EpiPen technically is.
I think we're out.
A little cheeky injection here and there.
I'll go first because I'm close to death.
Use me as fodder.
No, no.
We want you alive.
She...
Careful what you wish for.
I didn't think you'd jump on me so fast.
You're in my life of fire, peanuts.
He's chugging them pills.
They've given you adrenaline to keep you alive.
Do not hug the witch.
She'll down you faster than you saying,
Oh, shit.
All right.
Oh, thank you.
So maybe I will hug you.
I'm out of bullets.
You got pistols?
No, I'm not.
Hey, I'm reloading.
I'll chop them up through this fence.
Her day kid here.
Whoa.
Whoa!
We have AKs.
Oh, I like them.
Yepy.
Oh, wait.
Yoink.
That's 12.
Oh, my God.
They went out on the guns.
We reserve the right to refuse service to anyone.
Yeah.
I'll take the AK.
Talk to the gun shop owner.
Good morning.
Welcome.
There's a heal here.
Oh, I'm being healed.
Thank you.
Poorly is keeping me alive.
Let me grab another heal.
Single hand.
That's right.
For once, you guys are the heal slots.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
You keep us up.
This is what it feels like to be pampered.
This never happens.
What's that?
Your target laser upgrade makes your weapon more accurate.
Oh.
Get to go in there.
To get a laser sight?
Yeah, you want a laser sight?
It's back here.
It's in here.
I didn't see that there was a laser sight.
It is just this little thing in the bulb right here.
And then.
This?
Yeah.
Oh.
Apparently it gets more accurate.
Okay.
My ankles aren't good enough to jump off the balcony.
Yeah, I don't recommend it.
Talking for personal experience.
Oh.
Oh my God.
I remember you.
What?
I don't...
You walked the whole way around.
Oh.
Did I?
Whoops.
It's in.
I just like came down there.
I thought you could go over the hedge.
Are you ready to fight the horde?
Okay.
I'm ready to fight the horses.
Bring on the horses.
The rogatory though.
Behind your forward.
Where?
Retreat the cola inside.
Not me though.
No way.
Okay.
Are you in fire?
Are you?
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine.
I have health.
I scored the cola delivery.
What?
How did I kill the jockey?
Oh.
This is my maltone.
You put a maltone down in advance.
Five hits.
Cat.
Food.
My dispenser.
My beloved.
I love it.
I love editing stuff for Sheevee because it'll just fucking go off randomly.
I think I went off when I was recording something.
No.
Thanks for trailing stuff.
Yeah.
Sheevee recorded her doing this on like trailer.
And it was like, sorry.
Boomi was making noises in the background.
Let me try that one again.
And then it was like cat feeder thing goes off.
All right.
Sorry.
Let me try that one again.
I usually just edit all that out.
I'm like, I'll leave it in.
She'll get it.
She'll get it off.
I like doing it.
I'm actually kind of sad that I'm not going to edit much anymore.
But I really like.
Whoa.
I'm shooting.
I need to aim though.
Am I stuck?
Oh, there's people all around me.
All around me.
Me are familiar faces.
Four in all.
Thank you.
Reloading.
Would you be done for college?
Are you sick?
Yeah, I would.
That's why I was trying to have an FPS week because I was getting my FPS wraps up.
You know, we can grab here and reach them from behind when we do that game.
Oh, yeah.
We can use the most body shields.
Yeah.
Oh, what did you mean?
When you grab them from behind, you have direct voice chat open.
Like the microphone goes open to each other.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
That's the body shield thing.
And then you can.
Whoa.
You can see like really inappropriate stuff.
Like right into their ear holes.
These stream snipers may be shy, but we'll get one that talks.
I know it.
One of you will talk.
Don't you guys want to talk to us?
Why don't you talk to me, Lane?
Talk to me.
They're scared.
The one who's here.
Am I really that intimidating?
Who is that?
Where did that come from?
Who's there?
I didn't.
There's someone.
Someone around.
The weapons are like really strong.
I like it.
Like it feels like when I'm shooting, I'm actually doing stuff.
Getting sad.
The safe room.
Okay.
Thank you.
Did it poorly just say something?
I don't know.
I never heard anything.
I saw the like cat bubble thing.
The picture of the stressed out dog.
Who did the most damage to?
Oh, look at you, Strani with your 409 just behind me.
The AK is such a good weapon.
What weapon are you using?
I don't know what it's called.
M16.
The Pew Pew.
Killed the most special infected.
I'm like, hmm, there's something wiggling.
Shoot, shoot.
Thank you very much.
Oh, scar.
Yeah, it's a scar.
Guys, leave me alone.
I thought you were supposed to be the American.
They could be American.
I don't know.
I got my nose is stuffy.
I woke up from a nap.
Yeah, that's true.
My chat was there working.
I have a headache.
Give you some slack, guys.
Thank you for the extended three month membership.
Whoa.
Right.
Reflins, you're welcome to stream.
Snape and from my friends list.
You should be able to just see me and join game because there's no one in an
XC.
Sad cat.
Thanks for the extended membership.
I know I'm supposed to be in the middle of the club to do it, but I'm unprofessional.
Okay.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah.
Did you like, did you pin your friend code?
I can't even talk it.
Talk it.
Okay.
Nice English for one.
I can't even, I don't know.
I'll try again.
Okay.
You should be able to do it now.
Stream.
Steam.
Set team.
Account is scrawny tonight.
I can't let me talk.
Okay.
I think they fixed the talking.
I wish they would fix the freaking raid message issue.
That literally, like it's really nice redirecting into someone like the outside of the agency,
like if no one else is on or whatever.
But when they're like, who raided?
They're like, who is this?
I'm like, hi, it's me.
Yeah.
Sometimes I don't even say anything.
I'm just like, I'm too shy.
No.
I'm like, I'm too tired of the industry.
I'm like, fuck it.
I always say like, thank you for babysitting the refunds or something like that.
Chair, thank you for the three membership.
Oh my God.
Our freebies are today.
It's Wilfred motherfucking Wastash.
What a name.
Big Wilfred.
Someone's Markiplier fan over here.
Wilfred, do you talk?
Who's the other?
Hello, Wilfred.
There you go.
Next.
Do you talk?
Fuck's sake.
Name has mics.
The refunds were telling me that they don't even talk in game, that they don't have.
Again?
I heard that.
It's so quiet.
Yeah, you be out for us.
Oh, you're so quiet.
I forgot I was muted.
How do I make you talk?
Yeah.
How do I turn up game chat?
Voice transmit volume?
Tess?
Where's the voice transmit volume?
Speak.
Replace your low ammo weapon.
No.
I'm just going to get more ammo.
I'm going to heal it.
I heard that, but it's so quiet.
Yeah, it's still so quiet.
Oh, it's probably receive volume.
Why is this quiet?
I don't know.
Speak.
Fuck.
Good boy.
I know that reference.
That's the husky video.
Alright, speak, motherfuckers.
I am speaking.
Okay.
I turned up the receive, so that's what you got to turn up.
It's a little bit better.
Alright, now meow for me.
It's so quiet.
We're not going to be able to hear the ones who leave the safe room,
but I'll take it.
I'll take it.
I'm trying to get these pussies to meow for me and then not.
One of them meowed.
Oh, wait, I'm allowed to hold.
Okay.
I'm learning.
I'm ready.
Wow.
This would sound like Italian music.
Why does it say I'm protecting you with them?
I don't know.
I'm actually shooting right at you.
If somebody attacks me and you shoot,
but you just happen to shoot me at the same time.
Wait, those zombies are fighting each other.
I want to re-fund.
Look at these. They have really nice
mannequins
Getting distracted
We appear to be in what is known as a shopping mall. A shopping mall
Look at that. They've got escalators. That's when you know, they mean business when it's got big escalators
That's a big it's a big business when you get escalators
I
Was it cold and I heard there's like loads of abandoned
Malls in America because like money nobody. Yeah, nobody goes everybody's online. They just shop one line, too
Are you oh you're right next week
I'm like trying so hard right now. I'm enjoying this. This is like game. I recommend yeah, it's pretty fun
I'll be very interested to see how the 44 things go as I said, we're not going to do too much cam
I don't know if the campaign's like
Yes, you can come
Three two one go
I'm kidding. I'm teasing and teasing for a pleasing. Okay
I cannot scratch my eye. My eye is wondering what's happening
brought her to tears
For some
Love being abused
hell
Oh, I think I got a piece of cat here in my eye
I'm blind if I was playing this alone. I have to admit I'd be absolutely terrified right now
But I'm actually really good. Oh, I get terrified playing on my own like
In Elton ring like I've finished it now
The reefland like stream state me and hold my hand the entire way because I get too terrified to play on my own
Like I get so scared the moment. I can't spawn them in after a boss fight. That's so funny
Wait, what did you how far did you get did you get to the DLC? Yeah, we did everything together. You did everything
Yeah
I mean I commentate on their face. They do really well
That's so funny me who took like two hours to fight a boss
We just
I'm so stubborn
No, I want help and I'm like no you play it how they want to play it. There's someone crying. Can we rescue humans in this game?
That is not human
I got her. I thought we could save humans. I was like, oh, maybe there's more
That's how they trick you
No, you play it the right way like I saw the monkey game and I thought oh you'd like that a
It's like same kind of style and like you're like a proper gamer with it
I am not a proper gamer. You're a proper gamer for certain games. You just don't like souls likes
They're like, oh, are you gonna play like
Dark Souls 3 or something like that the most like well-recommended one and I'm like, well, if you can't carry my hand
And you'd probably be more scared because I feel like Dark Souls 3 is a little bit more scary
Like I get frustrated fast as well. Like it doesn't go my way. I'm raging. I'm like, no, I know you're you rage quit
No, literally like I have to purposely plan around games that I know I can complete or not gonna frustrate me because I played this
Old childhood game called blinks and I was fucking screaming at it. I was not having it
I
Also rage at elder drink sometimes I have to be like I have to take a step away
I'm going I was smashing my controller the other day
She clipped it and ship it boys. I can get a nice
Oh, you're by the way, I went and investigate. I was like actually yeah, I have sent these fucking shorts away like ages ago
What's going on? Oh, sorry, sorry
Maly them to
death
What is going on so much? I need space to shoot. I need space to shoot come which I kind of see
I'll take that
I
Spiked it multiple times the head to control area
Because I had a one controller that was already broken. I kept it around specifically so I could break it further. Oh
I get angry
Dwayne Ellen I
Have some adrenaline. Whoa. Oh, there's chippies. You got some ways. You got some cheetos
Doobie you gotta look like a
Almost
That what in the like five days at Freddy's to Foxy jumpscare was that
Sorry
I'm reloading I'm being ridden and not on my strap
Oh
Where's the fire alarm wait you turn it off, you know, you have to turn
And they just keep coming if we don't get up in time where I'm going I'm running
Where's the break? I promise we scouts are good at short distances. Oh
Jesus Christmas. I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. I'm stuck. I'm stuck
I'm going I'm going. I'm going. I'm dodging. I'm dodging. I'm sneaking. I'm so good
Sash, come on
I need that's it. I'm nuking myself. Fuck it. It's been great. It's been great. It's been fantastic. It really has
I just ran over you setting fire to you and an XE very nice
Now he's on fire other zombies like act like they're on fire
Oh
Can I raise you? Yeah, I had to deactivate this shit, bro. I need ammunition. Go go, Shawnee. Do it
I can't fucking the horde. So would think of the horde
This is why I chose Alliance
Literally
Wait the fucking alarm did we get it? Yeah, there you did it. Oh, I was letting you do it
But then I think one of them did it
Oh
Thank you
Yeah, that's fine. Can I stab you with it stab me with what? Oh the adrenaline probably
We'll let you figure this out
Sorry about that old chap you imagine watching yourself like slowly die
Oh, no, one of you guys take that take it
What if you take that?
Wait, I'll be your little heels flag. You're getting pocketed. Okay, don't resist. No, don't he'll
We should feel the people that actually
Okay, okay, you got you got boy in there. He got point that they'll be
There we go
Oh, thank you, you're welcome. I hope you do come well
I got a pipe off. Oh, there's a hole. I believe this thing is whole
Okay, we're good. We're good. We just fell over standing
Oh, we're all healed up
It's
It was in that
Oh, it was in that kids movie with the animals. Yeah
And the monkeys
I am eggy from yeah, Taryn Taryn egg your team. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, King'sman. Yeah, King'sman. Yeah, you know it
You've seen it. I love King'sman. Yeah, and I've seen that movie. I watched it with my mom
She likes movies. She just like watches kids movies because everything scares her
Honestly, I felt that mumbling
She she's just like you want to come over and watch the new um
Like if movie
I mean like
Or is it like it I can't remember it or if
Not the one with the evil clown
With the one with ryan reynolds and imaginary friends and i'm like mom
Why are you watching kids movies and she's like because everything else is bad
violent
Oh, look at his pictures of markiplier and then that one's an anime girl
Imagine we were playing a micro plier. Oh my god, the real
She's with the real slow shady. Please stand up. Did the most time the movie coming out mark
When's the movie? Where's where's iron long?
Uh
Right. Thank you so much for your service. Anybody know who the race car is?
I'm so sorry if I keep referring to the harem as reflin if you identify as a harem. I'm sorry
I'm very used to saying thank you for letting me play with you guys. Oh
Yeah, but what
You're welcome. I hope you had fun. Oh, they're already gone. It took me far to load
All around me or whoa, what the fuck does that mean share stream? No, get the
What?
Don't ask to watch my stream and steam
Something popped up. This is like
Yeah, I was like, uh, this this user is asking to watch your thingy and i'm like, no
You'll never guess what my youtube channel is for nor
All right. Oh, I can get a paddle. Oh my god. I have a cricket bat mail on stream real
Mail on stream
Actually true though
Get right. This is your chance to be the male vtuber that I hate so have fun. Oh
It's okay. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's a call back
Come here. Wait, someone needs to stream snake. They're we've still got a bot
Well, no, we have Jess. Jess isn't the name. Oh, I'm so sorry. I thought the jest was the character's name
I'm so I'm so sorry. I'm sorry. Okay. I'm small brain
No new ammo. I had to drop. Yeah, you don't deserve that king
I keep you lift lift your head up your headset falling off thing
What?
Right, there's no right. I'll take the defibrillators. I don't mind. Is Jess a woman
What does it say? Where is sedah?
This is not uh, no, no. Oh, disappointing. I was hoping we get like a girl hair and Marie Flynn
I can I can hardly hear she being I want to discord kitten. Don't believe the signs washing your hands won't help when my bad
The
gamers for crayon
What? Oh Croydon
Wait, london why is it london randomly?
Gamers for Croydon. Yeah, I know probably probably easter eggs that like
People have played the game. They just put something or maybe the dev team, right? We're ready. Yeah, shag them and tag them and drag them
Indeed
Oh
First thing that harem does is go into the ladies bathroom. What's going on here? Wait, it's going on here
Wait, it's going on. No, something's going on. That was me. I'm the harem. I'm the harlot
350 ping who was 350 paying?
Oh damn
How can you see because she's Australian? That's why
Wait, I'm not oh, no, I'm hosting it. Sorry. Yeah, I have two 16
I was about to feel like the internet came out
Excuse me. It appears. I have the problem. I truly am
We need to fill this car
Find a gas can
Well, there's one up there
I think
We missed them. Wait, that's
Oh my god, this is a big map
But in these circumstances, I think can I just jump out the window
I can't are you serious? I have to wait for this fucking stupid thing. Please be kid. Please don't jump
We you've already done it once
That wouldn't have been that wouldn't have been a fall. Is that any contact? I got it. I got a gas can
What do you do with it? I don't know
Oh
Oh, there's something there's like a weed. I'm pouring fuel
We 13 we gotta collect the 13 notes. Okay
Wait, so it's a real car. Did they display real cars in malls? Yeah
Can I jump down?
Reloading. Uh, what?
Are you serious? Uh, I have to get up to you. I'm coming. I'm coming. Sorry. I'm good. Jess got me. Okay. Okay
Very stupid. I try to jump over the edge and I
It's like a teammate must have helped you out
Oh, there's med kits in the next to the car to the uh
What happened to the gas can I dropped six p.m. Oh one of you guys I think already got it. Yeah
You dropped it on something where I cannot reach
Jess what have you done? Okay, I got it
All right. Yeah, hold on. I'm figuring out. I want the defibrillators in case someone goes down
I'll I'll give you the kiss. Was it the kiss of life. They call it if you get saved by
Someone giving me a the kiss of an angel
I'll be your I can be your angel and she'll be your devil. Oh wait, I'll be your angle and she'll be your devil
Yeah, I'll be your angle
Yeah, keep throwing them down I'll keep pouring them in
Can I throw them with that?
Oh, oh my god
Now that song is stuck in my head from saying
Oh, I got pills
They're multiple
Lips have an angel
Oh
Yeah, so we're doing karaoke together. Yeah, 100%
Uh, can somebody get my back, please
My neck
Stay on a line of fire. How can I not?
Oh my god
I'm just being having gas cans thrown at me
Oh, no, you're so low health. Hold on. Uh, the only question that's left about TV is a harem
Oh my god, I'm so close to death. Hold on. There's loads of medkits. Hold on. I can
The bar next to the car
There's a pack to help here
Well, the seven design is really good because I can hear exactly where they're coming from. I know, right?
Where's the other two? Oh, it's right here. Oh, what's up?
Hell, oh my god, Shrani's like carrying me. Um, I got a can
I don't even know how I'm doing this so well to be honest
Maybe because I put on easy mode. Who said that?
Who said I did not this is a legendary mode. What are we talking about?
Red stew has arrived. Get on board. Get in the car. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm literally stuck. Oh
Cussing we got cussing
You mean legendary
Oh my god, like a kill cussing survive the dead center campaign the survive we escaped
Okay, oh my god, we get credited
I love games. I love games that credit you. Oh my god. Damn right. I'm coach. Um, put me in coach number of
Number of deaths first aid kit to use
This is zero everything guy. Yeah, I didn't know but if it came out, it wouldn't like count you or something
Do like blues brothers and drive around the mall honestly
Common infected kill
Um, oh yeah killed the most infected strongy with four we're gonna be at the top of the lobby all the time
Right, we'll do
And then we'll do that four v four game mode. Whatever it is. I have no idea what it involves, but we're gonna do it
We're gonna do it. Let's do it seven hundred and seven zombies were harmed in the making of this
Took a number. I love this game
Well, this is no wonder it's so well received. This is like such a good game
Right, so edit game sentence is without change the map chapter
Wait, we could do the campaign in one day
Tempting but how much time do you have my darling shady?
Girl, I got nothing going on. I'm gonna go get some more water. Okay. Actually hold on. I need to feed my cat
Yes, do that. Do that. Do that. I need to feed fia
Because the thing went off 20 minutes ago. Wait, it's a different map. Oh, oh wait, hold on
Play camping play with pals
Free of lobby, but not that. Oh, oh no, we cannot complete the campaign
There's too much
I don't have my headphones on so I can hear you. We're trying to be talking shit right now. I'm like, four v four. I'm not talking. I'm never talking about you
I kiss you. I'm gonna kiss you on your hot mouth
Oh the floor is sticky
Why is the floor sticky?
I was surprised. I was over airing it
Please play numerically. Oh, I was gonna do it in order
I think what I'll do is I'll play one more campaign
For this stream snip and then we'll do the four v four game mode just for the rest for the shits and giggles
And then I'll play the campaign
With the reforges at a later date. We'll do the campaign together because I thoroughly enjoy this game
I'm enjoying it. I did not realize how good it was. Like this is 10 out of 10
Oh
Hello, are you hunky? Hello, thank you for waiting munch munch munch munch
All right, I'm just
That was me. That was my pc. Sorry reforges and theorem
Um, uh
Why am I alone? I'm I'm having to start a new map don't worry. Um
Uh, so what we'll do is we'll play one more. Um
Don't snipe the fucking lobby she's not in
I'm I'm getting in hold on. I'm just no don't snipe the fucking lobby. She's not yeah, it said there's not enough slots
The navy dinner the navy dinner don't do that. He's not do that
Don't do that
Right play with friends. It takes me long enough to create the lobby. Okay. Please be nice to me. This is not easy for me to do
Right, no one come in
Right, and then share bearer. Hello. Hi, marie
Just
Wait until she's
Okay, and then you can do your free throw
Okay, hold on. I have to pee. Okay. No, that's fine. That's fine. I'm gonna mute but
Hold on. I need a mute on discord and on my chat chief of poll. Oh, wait. No, I press this button
Keep this for me. As in
Does that say master kush? I swear it goes. That says master kush
It so does doesn't it
What is her name?
Well, I can't see you
I'm so oh you're playing satisfactory. Yes, that's factor 1.0 came out master keith it told
He he he peeler allegation
I can't believe I have to unironically message a talent and say, hey, have you peed on an audio yet for your bonus unreward?
Hey, hey, can you piss?
Hey
Right, anyway, sorry. Um, as you can imagine, I'm rather
Hello
Can you hear me? Can't hear anything
Mummy next time you can just change the campaign and the lobby. Oh
So be there satisfactory collab wins. I'm gonna give it a shot offline to see if I'll be able to play it or not
I'm not sure though
Sorry for taking she be spot early about no, don't actually be sorry. I'm not actually mad
It's just because I know she be needs to come in
But if people are trying to stream snipe the slot before I can even get she be in I'm like
Give me a moment. Um as for my lovely leaflings. Um
Sorry here. Um, I know you're lurking in the ship. I apologize. Um
I will most likely play left for dead campaign with the reefland
So you guys can stream snipe me for the campaign and we'll have some shenanigans afterwards. I'm not gonna ask she be of too much time
however, um
Because uh, she's working on her finalizing the donor thon and we're we're getting some, you know assets and all that
Try not to assume why this a
So I'm not gonna ask too much time
Do I count down from win to enter? Are you three?
seven
Two you're getting closer
One
You're almost the lead to enter
Zero you can come and the lobby
You
Mummy don't mind me if I'm rubbish. I'm a bit rusty. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
We're literally playing easy mode because I've never played this game before but can I just say
For when does this game come out? I'm I'm pleasantly surprised
um
How like how good it feels like the guns feel nice the weaponry feels nice
Um, it doesn't feel overwhelming the audio cues are fantastically placed like fantastically played. This is lovely game 2009. Okay
this
I must say this game. Uh, I might rank it a 10 out of 10 already. Like it's so fair. Um
It's so
Like consider it to the player if you want, um, there's medical supplies where you need them
Uh, just I think this is a fucking well rounded polished game. I don't know how long development was. I wouldn't mind. Uh
but yeah
This is really good
Really really good
I know it was highly rated, but I just never got a chance to play it. The game director is very nice
Are you nervous? Wait, you're nervous. Why are you nervous to play with me? I'm not gonna say anything mean
I'm not a mean evil beanie
Don't be nervous to play with me because it's about development was one year. They put this together in a year
The mechanics are easy to pick up. The gunplay is great and it switches up. Um tanks
Oh, it switches up. Thanks to the director
Yeah, Left 4 Dead was released
It's actually more generous
The shittier you play more mid spawn when your teams have lower health
Eventually, I think I fell down. I don't know. Yeah, two cute girls feeding my cast would speak amongst yourselves
No, we're just sort of discussing the game. Um
And uh, I'm seeing that's a really good game. I'm I'm very pleasantly surprised
I I just never got the opportunity to play it and I'm so glad that I get to play
But I mean fuck like this is gonna be unironically not to get sappy or anything
This is gonna be cemented in my heart because not only did I get to play the game for the first time
I got to do it with sheebie and I also got to do it with harem and reefland
Like are you going are you trying to make me cry right now? No, I will cry everywhere
I was serious like I get to
Like I stream snip all over the reefland
But so what happened was on the schedule I planned this game
But I was just it was just gonna be me and you reeflands
And then she be messaged me out of nowhere. She was um, I didn't expect it and she was like, can I play with you?
And I'm like, uh, yes
You want to stream stick together?
Like the thought didn't even cross my mind that it was even possible that I could collab
And also play at the same time at like both ways and like I'm just
I'm very I'm a very happy being right now that I get to experience this for the first time with you
It's very nice. My heart is very filled. So thank you for I'm so happy
Yeah, thank you for asking seriously because I it didn't cross my mind that it was possible
Yeah
I was like, oh
Harem has been asking like if what I'm gonna do left for two again
And I'm like, I don't know. I really don't have anyone to play with and then I saw it on her schedule
And I'm like, oh, maybe strongy will let me play with her in the reeflings and then she said yes
Are you serious? Yes
Uh, right had the putters been fed check on boomi been fed
Uh, boomi is currently eating. I'm still feeding fia. Okay, little fia. Sorry. She is taking her time
She's good. No, she's allowed to take all the time. She won't
She is a madam
Of a high caliber
Here will you eat from my hand ma'am?
Sometimes she needs to switch between the bowl in my hand. I don't know why
It has a good mods community as well. Can I put bigger boobs on my model?
And you're a guy, I imagine. Oh
Oh, I wonder what's gonna be a guy in the next one. All the men have to
You unironically can there's a mod for that
To make them all have boobies
Wait, can I make all the zombies like zombie girls and it's like, oh, no, they won
They won. I don't know something. I want my cummies
They won the ink. You will never have the refling ink. It's inside me all along
But yeah, are you done?
There's a lot different mods, so I wouldn't be surprised if you can. I had anime girls as zombies
If you ask someone they can make a model of you and the girls
What? No, just too much. Imagine us, us as a game
That's too much to ask for. I think I'll do minecraft skins. How about that?
I'll be a cheeky sod and ask for minecraft skins if anyone knows how to make them
So I don't have to pay someone to do it because I don't know how it works
They're pretty, they're pretty cheap though. I got like a really good minecraft skin for like 15 bucks
I think
A Cod Zombie Baby
You can have rule 34 mod support in Leopardy 2. I don't think we'll be streaming that one
Uh, however, I'm glad that you do
And I'm booted up, I'm booted up
She is like a picky eater today because she's constipated. She has like a fat belly
Because she hasn't pooped in like two days
I feel so bad
Do you have what's called a licky lick in America? It's just like a tube of liquid food
But oh, yeah, treat each tube. Those will get some water in there. I think yeah. Oh, no, she'll drink water
It's like the food. It's like she knows
It's because of her medication. She has like a little pot belly right now. I feel so bad
I usually give her like mere lax and then that are like a lax
I honestly thought you were about to say I give her an enema and I was like, oh, I could
I won't
I don't want to give up an enema
No, I was gonna I was like resisting saying that
I was um
I have a I used to have a boy cat and he was the funniest cat ever proofing back in Scotland. Um
And I took him to the vet
Uh, and he was really attached to me. So he purred a lot. Um, he was bean little bean
Um, and he was attached to me at the hip
So he used to purr and he was at the vet, but he was purring every time I interacted with him
And then he got a thermometer shoved up, you know, where and then he burst out purring even louder and I was like, what's going on here?
I
Like the vet started laughing as well because all of us were like staring at the cat like excuse you
Like because obviously the vets are like, oh the cat hates this part. So just hold them down or whatever
And he starts purring louder. I'm like, uh bean have you got something you'd like to tell us?
Bean like something stuck up as bean
Although some cats like to purr like for anxious is like self soothing. So hopefully
That cat was rifling coated right you're done. Don't don't type about my callie
And hair I'm coated to be honest
Oh, I oh wait. No, I'm only it's water. Boomi. It's just water come down. Boomi's like trying to steal food
I need to give the kitty her meds
Little pooters is a liquid medication stuff. Yes. Oh, that'll be easier for her to take
Yeah, it's uh fish flavored
So she does it's she takes it like a churu like one of those little tubes. I'm different
Thank you staff for the tip this game popularized for player horde shooting and they all draw some inspiration from this game
The mod that came with this and other valve games help innovate the modding community as well
Oh
I believe it
No, I didn't I don't believe that very much too. Uh narrow a cod zombies on black ops 2 stream would be fun
Did they fix the servers on that one?
Yeah
Ti crimson. Thank you for the extended membership
Just got home. How are they doing you guys protecting our favorite girls? They're scared of us
We've had like
Two people talking the mic and no one else
We're playing one more round of the campaign and then we're going to be playing a game mode which is floor v4
um
So we'll take it from there
Honestly, I'll make sure to thank for all the tips at the end
You can thank all those messages. I'll read your tips right now. Show me them
I'll read them out for you. Well, you know, okay
It's so I think thank you leo. I still say she beats background music sounds like the music from persona 5
Thank you no one special just want to make sure your air sprays. Okay. I got the one before
Thank you. Good. No one special then. Thank you anonymous
YouTube came after the whole core. This is when the chat went down
No, I remember. Thank you doki. We've been silenced. Thank you. There need to be chat is broken in both streams. Hey
This is sad. It's like a reliving trauma. Don't help us madam. We're stuck in the void
My cat boomie apparently donated two dollars. Guess this is the only way to chat. Damn you neil
Chat is broken today. I guess we're chatting over tips now. Thank you
You're grand you're again son
You were you were playing with us. So thank you. Thank you for playing with us as well
You know, I can never pronounce your name
All right, fia has gotten her meds
She has been fed and watered
We're showing each other the tips real
I want to read the
Just the
Sorry, oh my
I got bit. I was actually hating at this whole time that boy. Yeah, I was like you're you're transforming into something
I took I took some meds. So hopefully my headache goes away
I took I took an allergy pill an allergy pill and uh a pseudofed
So because I have like some congestion. I think that's what's giving me headache because I want to keep playing
Yes
Oh, yeah, fuck you have a migraine
No, hopefully it goes I'll play for as long as I can and then you guys can just stream snipe without me
Okay, I'll probably be like, yeah
Too much because I'm screaming down the mic being like I say
Oh, that's fine. Like it's really like motion motion stuff might get me. Um, you need some lemonade. I'm drinking water
Why would you need lemonade for that? Is that cure or am I being dumb? I need some piss. Um, I don't know actually
I didn't sin with a zero
Uh, I could just be having like I think I like um, I like moved my neck a certain way
Like could that that could also be the reason like I got arthritis in my neck. So, oh no, you're joking. You're so young
I know I have arthritis on both sides of my neck and my shoulders
I'm destined to get uh
On my hands and my wrists
But I've not had it. I was not started yet. Uh, but my grand like had
fucked up hands and wrists
Uh, because of it. So I'm destined unfortunately because it was on my on my dad's
Carpal tunnel. Yeah, my mom got it around my age too
She didn't expect me to get I immediately I got arthritis after getting coven
No, I had the weirdest thing. That's when I got diagnosed with fibro
That's when I got arthritis all after I had co I had no symptoms before that
And then it set off like a genetic bomb in my body. Oh my god, that's crazy
I'm like, I'm too young at the ripe age of 56
You know
Haggle up
This is how we kiss each other
Uh, right are the putters being fed?
Yes, did you hear boomie just then? No, I didn't actually he just went
Uh
He sounds like he just peed and ran away from the litter box. Uh, why did cats do that?
Oh my god, gimme takes a big massive shite and then starts running through the house. I'm like
They're like I feel so much lighter
I literally it feels like a feather start floating around the house like
Gimli get done get done pink get done
No, boomie, you can't hop up here. You're just in the freaking litter box. You gross cat go away
Are we ready to start? I'm ready ready five nights. I'm ready
Is this what you want to go? I just don't get it
It looks like faces were edited on top of the bodies
We should edit our people in my loading screen
Nobody survives the inking forever
You'll ink one way or another one way or another. We're gonna ink you
Get the one way
This is a fun net fun fun map
Is it? Yeah, I don't know which map we played before when I played with the you may plus girls. Oh, pardon me
T I was interjecting wrong
You're fine bad streaming
How dare you speak
Speak unless
She is so beautiful
It's raining. He's got it. We'll see you on the other side
Uh, hello, hello, oh the dying. Hello. Hello bark bark for us now bark
How they actually did it they put dinner at the same time proof that heroin refins are in sync
Literal handshake. I love it handshakes. Oh
Oh, they're starting. Oh, you're you're a black lady now. Oh my god. I'm stevie. Oh, it's me
Are you awake?
I'm a white man
As I was meant to be
Oh, you're white. Ah, if you're awake and we could swap say
Like team
Trouble and terrorist
Oh my gosh. Oh mean we got to play ttt
Well, maybe let me do the gary's mod test stream. Oh, sorry. It's off. It's not an off club
It's a off off stream collab because I'm sorry. We're testing stuff out. Maybe we can play uh ttt and prop on it
If she be leaks it i'm allowed to leak it
Guys, we're gonna put a gmod together. I'm so excited. I've never played gmod before that's another game
Oh, you're gonna have so much fun. If you like this, you're gonna have fun
Hi miwa
Miwa saying not the transracial stream
Oh my god, what was that freaking marshmallow you got? It was a copy pasta
I thought it was real watch out. I thought it was real too, but then I realized wait. No, it's a copy pasta
Okay, and I was
What i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming
Don't touch the car saved you saved uh chief of polif
May don't oh, I get it. Is it like chief of police? I'm crouching around the car
Don't touch the car. Don't touch it. Just look look with your eyes touch with your eyes touch with your eyes
Oh, I can't none of us can get in
Wow
Even the convenience stores in the south have guns. There's stuff on the other side
Oh, we got it. Can you melee in?
You can go through the window. Sorry. Oh my god
Oh, jeez. I love this gun. I think it's an uzi
Get adrenaline. No, come eat. What is that? You're just fucking going. How did you guys get in? Hold on a minute? Oh, oh, oh
Yeah, that's right. You got it. You got it. You got it. Yeah
Actually, let me take the shotgun this time
Which way do we go now? Oh, I think this way
I don't like that. I don't I don't like that one. They're kids. I don't like being in the bathroom alone
Okay, we can go upstairs
Up the stairs. He's coming up the stairs. Oh, that's where that clip is from jeez
Oh
Sorry, there was a thing in the way
That was really funny. Um
There's like this clip where it's like morgan freeming and i'm creeping around
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's deep. No. No. No, that was uh, I think they're playing stalker
Oh, is that not
No, that's not gmod
I think please myself played myself
Hey, I got an achievement. I should probably not use this. I have no idea what this is
Pow right in the kisser
Yeah, all right
I'm more focused on talking than uh
I've been actually playing the games. I'm just walking around and firing wildly
The best kind of no, but those are the best games where you can just yap your head off
I was playing solo and chained and just absolutely the labbing and blabbing and blabbing and blabbing and blabbing
In the distance, there's a halt
the two
Someone said they have 2000 hp and apparently they have a music track
I'm scared. I'm stuck on the car. I can't see because of the names. I can't see
Oh
Okay, um empty enough. Okay. He's gone. Nice
Nice job. Oh tech ninja. Where are you brother? Come here. Come here. Come here. Nope healing myself
Uh, it's ray get healed scrub moose button to put it on someone else to be a we heal
Watch out some cars set off alarms. Don't why are you crouching because the car alarm's gonna go off and then
It's only if you shoot them. Oh
That was the dude I just healed
I have
I was sneaking I was that was like
Ah, oh
He's got shot off the map
Over here
I don't want to get I'm closing the door. They can't come in if we close the door. I don't want to get pinned
I hear screeching. Oh my god. They're breaking my door
Do you know how much I paid for that? I just got this down mortgage. I got incendiary ammo
You got dragon spruce
I can share it with you guys. Oh frick. I just fell. I like I'm gonna drop it. Where are you?
Deploying incendiary ammo
Oh
I've got her six. Don't you worry
You like that boom. So it's in the next astronomy. It's over here
Oh, I'm so low ammo though. He uses for like five
Oh
I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. Kill a jokey within two seconds of it jumping on a survivor. I've got an achievement
All right denied
reflin scrub it up. It's time to get in the tub
You guys want to come in the tub with us?
Oh my god
Rub it in the tub
We're hanging in the tub
What is happening down there?
You want to come in there?
What did I just walk into?
I'm dying and you guys are taking a bath
All right, no more no more erp in in the middle of lifer dead
Oh
Thank you for the heels madame. I saw yours. Ta-da. Oh, I feel so good brand spanking new
Right oh right from debut
Where do we go now?
I'm looking at are we all lost? Where are we going?
Lead the way reflings and haram
We gotta go up
Say no more
Back in the tub
Like here wait, how did you get up there? She?
Oh the stairs
Yeah, you know the staircase. Yeah, just the power of flight
He on us. Oh, there's guns. Where exactly?
They're over here. They're over here
Mmm. Yummy. Yummy
I have gotten this all right my nose. It's just
Server stream 2.0
You'll never guess
Oh
Through this park. All right through this park. Let's go
Oh, oh, yeah, I'm spraying. I'm praying. I assure you
He's on fire. It's Emmy. Look. It's her green dress. Oh in me. Oh the body's really disappeared quick
It's blue for me
for green shoes
She didn't look too good. Oh, I wonder it must be in there. There's a witch up there. Oh, it's a wedding
No, don't touch. Don't touch flashlights off. How do you turn them off? Oh?
I think she's region anyway
Can't I just shoot her? Well you why can't I just shoot her?
Do you want to
Yeah, I'll back you up if you want to shoot her. All right. I'm back fucking
What is going on who is shooting freaking bomba?
I don't want to I don't want to sneak pass. I'm not going in sneaky beaky. I'm I'm killing bitches
No sneaky beaky. We do cheeky bricky only
Exactly
All guns
All guns no trigger discipline
Guns are blazing
Oh my god, listen to the sound design. Oh my god. It's like ASMR in here. I know it's it does go ear to ear
Look at that
It's like so ASMR listen to the pet or pattern
I can't I'm fighting off zombies right now
Oh, is that the safe house over there? Oh, no, okay
Reloaded
So are we just
Special or are we just built different in terms of the lore of how I we survive?
But everyone else is a zombie. We've not met like one other human yet
Well, there's a there's a dude on the intercom that owned the gun shop
You it
I'm trying to keep up
Yeah
It's been great gentlemen. Yay. We did it. We did it chicken fries. Strati carrying
Well, so people are the dude you carried more against the tank. He did more damage
But you're literally 20 points behind me, man
I look my gun just go pew pew and sometimes the bullets connect sometimes they don't it's a toss up
If it works, you know, thank you very much for your service. Thank you
Thank you
Thank you for playing with us. We're spray supposed to be a reflame just now
Strati kills 12 special infected. What the hell? I don't even I'm just shooting when there looks like there's something bad
Stop working
Farewell
It was fun, you're so right preach preach to the choir because it's working
Who we're going to get next you have like back issues. You got scoliosis or her dumpy is just huge
I haven't heard that in a long time
I want to do a game show for viewer, but I have no idea how to implement that
I'm going to be doing my research over the next few ones
But I wanted to do one about vines brain rot effect. Oh, I will win
hard
I was gonna make it that the prize is someone gets a $300 skeb whoever wins
What?
Yeah, or or you can just take the $300
No, I'm excited about the skeb. Uh, I will be winning that. Thank you very much
Well, I thought but I just need to figure out how to do it right who we got
We've got definitely not john. I'll write your name down because you have a chance to play
And then for the other
Or hear him
Sorry, I do apologize. Who we got we've got
Rune distillation
A little harlot. It's funny because we've been getting like a harlot in a reefling almost every time
It's almost like we got too hard a lot in common. We should just make out she be
We need ship art I need I need a saucy skeb
Of uh me and scrawny
And I say saucy we're just eating tomato soup. That's it. No
Awesome, uh, do you guys talk? Do you want to bark?
Want to bark for us? Huh? Yeah, I'm ready already
You think emmy would win that? No
Emmy would not win because it is before her time. She has tick tock brain rot. I have vine brain rot
I heard that
Is that in game?
No, so they were talking are you yapping?
Speaker
That's it one bark no more your turn we won't
I know and if nothing came through we just had to make fun
Come on is your mic broken
We're gonna bully you a lot of the makes are broken
That might be how do you talking to him? What's fine? Mari, please? I don't know how you talking to him. Sorry
Must be oh no, it's microphones broken. Right. Are we ready?
He's lying. I don't I don't believe him. There's a hand coming through the door
Give him a little hand jubby. Oh
I'm ready when you are
Door has been opened
Door stuck
Let the you know let them go first, you know
Let them scope the area. You know how it is. Any tactical teams?
Yeah, actually I want a different gun. Why do I still have them?
This is a nice little road
Very cute. It was like a red lake this week. Yeah, I think they're you got a tattooist. I think they got uh girls
Oh, it's called club d
Do I have a deagle?
You play cs. Yeah
You just play a lot of cs
I don't 600 hours combined forces. I haven't played cs in a long time
But if you're familiar
I will play cs with you charney. I will play any game with you. You know this already
Oh
We just have a weekly stream together. It's just on the roster forever now
Something's making big noise. Is that a witch or is this a I heard a big no, it's just a girl. It's just a girl
Oh
I heard a train
That was a truck, but it did sound like a train for some reason. That was very confusing
Oh, it's called
Red light bar cafe. So I guess
Yeah, we could totally win the public cs go lobbies, right? If we all shoot six did it together, right?
Can the enemies here isn't cs go?
Oh, no
Oh
Well, help technically in like lobbies. Yeah
Um, but because like you're against the team and usually you can't hear the other team
Yeah, it's all like uh, it's it's a lot of of court. It's the same exact weapons because it's also made in source. Um
And it's usually like you have to like crouch and like do your
like weapon spray and there's I remember just freaking
Studying that for hours trying to get the rights like
Hold down spray pattern shit
Somebody upstairs
Oh
He's exploded in there. Um, do we where do we go?
Is this not it? No, we came from here
Wait, we can oh, I think you're going the right way. There's a there's a heels
I don't
Oh, no, you're right
Oh
I'm getting bubbled. I'm getting bubbled. Oh, it dropped. Good thing that there is a
For shake it right here. Literally. Did they drop that? Did they drop the specials drop items?
No, that was already there. What is this?
I have a
What?
Oh, we go up. Oh, I would go up and say
Where oh, yeah, there's going up the ventilation chair
Uh, oh, can I get some money?
Money money money
Oh here it is. I was like, how do we get up to the fire escape because I'm pretty sure that's where we go
Ah, oh this is like, New York when they have all those fire escape rooms
I don't know how to shot past you
Stop exploring on your own
What guys how are you even
Oh, I don't even know how you're floating like that. Are you good?
I was being hung on like the tongue
Yeah, that's a strong ass tongue. I've got explosive ammo
You know me there and must be Italian
I'm about on the street
Rather than a back on the street
I
Just watching you out the window
Seems like it cuz there's new
That's me you're going the right way
Okay, now pop that I know where I
Have a buyer
Why is she purple?
Oh strange very dark press F to turn on your flash
I
Wish I had a chainsaw. Oh, we're work. Oh
Was a boomer. That was confused. Oh
God, there's so many
You should do a party. We'll keep boomer. Okay, boomie. Whatever you say
Okay
Yeah, oh my god, that would be so cute. Oh, we actually really cute. Oh, that's actually a good idea
I will take an adrenaline shot
Yeah, the haremling can heal themselves they have a heel
Uh
Okay, I got it. We were a bit old
Okay, I'm fine. What a unique enemy. Is it dead? No come back if you're gonna lick me at least let me kill you
Oh, yeah, that's the one that's the smokers one that grabs you with the tongue. I
Don't know why
I do like the enemy's very
Yeah, they're pretty cool. Definitely scary. Mm-hmm. I
Don't like enemies that can grab you
I like that. It removes your ability to play until your team needs help. Yeah, the whole point is the place together
Oh
This is actually a horror game
It's when they come out of nowhere when you didn't expect it like you don't hear the audio
Yeah
Sorry
Can you stop shooting me? Yeah, what is this poop water and I
Like
Oh, it works. I don't know what is going on. I hope you're okay
Hope you're okay
Okay, I stuck up there
Get off my jock
Joachy I can't get up here. That's us. We can ask you something embarrassing. Of course
What's the joke? Oh
I can't tell you because so I was like a jockstrap otherwise known as the banana hammock
I was a I was looking at lingerie with the with the harlots in one of my streams
And we were looking at jockstraps and I was trying it's like almost like a thong for men. Oh
It's like, yeah
It'll be a moment to think of what it was for a second
Y'all ready, so I'm like you guys should buy them and then you know you use it in a bedroom
I don't I think guys just wear them. I
Think it's like the equivalent of like girls wearing a thong, right?
What do we do we jump girls wearing? Oh, I'm like girls right we wear thongs
You wear clothes
I
Thought it was just like a male thong. I didn't think it was like a cup thing
Right keep moving keep moving up the ladder up the ladder up the ladder come on move out move out move out
But I like the pool water. I can't run to the same room this fucking lady
Oh
Where's the ladder go
Come on guys
How are they jumping up and climbing like that I'm getting done. All right, I can move now jeez. Yeah
I was just getting standing
Getting wallet, right? Everyone's here. Everyone's here. Yeah. We're all here. We're all here protect
It's mostly related to sports. Oh, oh, there's more like a breath. Oh avoid the noxious acid
I'm stuck. Oh my god. Uh, hello
I'm trying and you don't hit you
I don't think there's something fire like actual damage so
I don't know
Well, if I shoot you right now
Yeah, help isn't going down. Is it not?
No
Why do they pretend to I mean, I guess maybe it's just for
We go in the tunnels. Stop shooting each other
Pardon me
Jesus Christ
Oh
Run past all of us. All right. Um getting stung long
I have a d-fib
That's good because
Heal yourself. I know. Yeah, I see ruin is on his last leg. Yeah
We can make it. Come on. Don't give up. Of course the noxious acid is by the fluffy ladder
This one is stuck. I love glitches and uh, right. I'm nuking myself. It's been lovely. It's been lovely. No, really
It's been an absolute pleasure. Oh
You nuked us too by the way
Oh, hey, there's health up here though
You need it more than I do
Oh, this dude is running away. He ran into the safe room. Oh, there's a safe room
How did he run into the safe room? That's so weird. God, um, make it right now
I'm feeling so hard right now. I have to heal
Oh, I've healed so hard
Oh, it doesn't even feel so hard. Motherfuckers want to find me. Oh, we rocked to close the door. That's why
Whipsies
Yeah, no friendly fire on easy
Do you mean easy?
Oh
These accusations that I only play games on easy mode of shopping. I don't know why I'm not there
Surely. I don't know
Can I get over how nice the weaponry feels in this game?
Which is what one would say a 10 out of 10. I reach it very highly
Thanks for the game
You're welcome. Thanks for barking
I would like to see
Mercy and Icy play this game
We should feel like Icy would just be screaming the entire time. So would mercy
Does mercy emotions look amazing?
Probably
I've found it very hard to I can't figure out what games make messes thick and not
I think first person she's okay and its third person is the problem
Oh, I think if it's over the shoulder and the camera isn't
Oh focused, then that's what gives her emotion quick now
Okay, we got label label and we got to reluctantly saying hello
You know what to do
Already comes pre-trained
Yeah, pre-trains. Hello. Hello Loita. That's good. Oh, hello
Barney bark
Bark bark
Dude, I never heard it bark motherfucker
Uh, no, don't say the word bark. You have to go feral
You have to you have to prove how much we've corrupted you how much we've
With with me with grimdue. Okay, do you know how long it takes to grim you what banana for months? No
He said hello you can
Hey, did you did you say it? I think I think you went woof woof. I think okay
I'm whatever I guess you're safe for now label label. If that's your real name
Yeah, exactly. Okay. He's not he's not and he did bark. It just doesn't come through that well. Okay. Are we ready?
Oh, he did it again
Right ready
All right, let me let me in let me in
Where's any camera?
Maybe oh, we'll see there's people. Oh wait. Hello. You just need to fill that generator and we can why are you shooting?
You from up here
Yeah, I stayed here. Oh, I'm okay. I'm just a little banged up
It wasn't easy getting up here. Is your leg fucking broken brother. I think he's been
Hated it. Yeah, we'll help you. Do you want to come along with us?
The left or dead one crew is it? But oh, that's funny. I didn't know that
I thought I recognized them. Okay, but if you change your mind, that's cool. Okay
Oh, so the left or dead two takes off where the other team finished. That's so cool
I like we love continuity and sequels with new players shadow is really funny. Yeah, we love sequels that are actually sequels
Notice they're missing one person
No, no, they're all here
I think I think they're fourth perished
and
Spoiler oh true
No, at least there's ammo right here. Oh
No, I'm being ridden
Oh, I was shooting a human. Oh, so was I
It look we're a bit used to just sprain and play and do forgive us
But sorry about that. Sorry. Sorry. It's just a wee bit of a misunderstanding
Oh, we got to get gas cans. Okay. We gotta do this gas can retrieval thing again. Jesus Christ
Ah
Where is the closest? Yeah, it's a gas again. Yeah, you're gonna build up the generator tonight
Where can I get to this generator? I mean this gas can
Where oh, that's over here go away. This looks suspiciously like a massive trap
And I'm not sure
Oh, I found a katana. Don't mind if I do
Katana
Oh, she's named after a sharp weapon
Oh my gosh, I get it now. I get it now
Oh
Oh, I keep getting fucking stuck
This is not the easiest map
Oh, yeah, I'm getting fucking pinned again. Thank you for leaving me
I
Oh, I don't have rest. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. It was worth it. It's been lovely. It really has
Where are you? I'm fucking you can I always just do a lot of self-cult fail
I heard these tanks so spread out. Oh my god
It's throwing a slab of concrete at me
What? How does he even comprehend?
It picked up the floor and throw it
She's slow way
Well that that's a bit dramatic for a zombie. Don't you think?
That's a great question. Why doesn't anything have enough gas in it?
Oh, thank you. Did you know that during a real zombie apocalypse that going for gasoline
Is it the smartest thing to do because it doesn't have good preservation? Yep
There's no point because it did you know that it's most likely
That seeds will be a very high commodity to grow your own food and become farmers again if a zombie
I watch the walking dead I get it. Oh, you watch the I watch the what do you need help? I'm helping. I'm helping
Oh, you're getting you're getting caught. Oh, I'm getting caught too. Hold on a minute. Let me pick you up
Ah
I have a deep in
Oh, I have a heal kit
Oh
If we can't hurt each other, I'm spraying and spraying
Oh, I'm helping. I'm helping. Oh, there's a thing back there. Why are you getting?
Uh, do you I think uh, oh I defend myself
Uh
Who are you fiving? You can't
I defend you
Oh, I fell in my own gas
Can I defend you?
Oh, wait, you're not dead dead. So it doesn't matter
I'm not dead yet. Oh, no
Okay, I help I was trying to get you and I got attacked by something. Oh god
This is but why is this map so hard? Did I make it normal?
I don't think this is easy
I mean super different expert modes. Oh, where is this fucking smoker?
Smoker that got me. We literally I was gonna say we literally cannot. Can someone pick up?
Someone pick him up. I got him. Okay. I'm gonna kill the zombies around him
Get him Labeel. I got you. I'm covering. I have one health
Why oh did I miss the memo? How did I just go down?
No
What what happened
Is that supposed to happen legendary mode
It literally I told you I was playing legendary mode. None of you's believe me. They're just not yours. They're strong easy
No, it doesn't I just have we have it says easy
I wish I had that defense
So no, no, no, no, we never got to win. You have to win. No, you have to win. You have to stay
You're not allowed to leave until we win
It doesn't count. That's not how it works. Right. Okay. Thank you. So what did I do shotgun? I lost my katana
No, I prefer the assault rifle. I'm an assault rifle gal. You know what I'm saying? I'm an assault rifle gal
All right, I'll talk to these
goofballs again
Hey
It gets harder the more gas cans you get so you better see oh
So don't put them in just grab the cans and put them to the side
Okay
The caller stays on until mommy wins. Exactly. Oh, that's right
Let's get you on your way. All right. I won't get any gas in this generator
But we'll we'll get our stocks up for stonks. It'll be super duper high
The highest
They're locked in with strunnion she be. They must be terrified
Literally, you're forced to stay away. I don't care if you've got work. You've got responsibilities. They're forced
We are not leaving until we get to take priority. I will take this pipe bomb. Thank you very much
All right, so I guess
Just bring it over. Grab them and bring me. I keep doing that. I keep doing that right over that. She's a nice lady. She didn't she's protecting
Where that we went down that was like over where
Okay, is that one all the way over here? I can grab
one two
And then we just put them all in it once
Very gently go away
Right, that's a horde sound. So I'm gonna purposefully stay behind with the mpc until the horde sound goes away
I'm not getting shagged at all. Why am I on fire?
Because you're feeling hot hot hot
They accidentally blow up the gas can that I have. Can you do that? Well a response
I know it respawned it respawned
All right, I need to make sure we're doing
Wait, wait, wait, don't put them in don't put them in don't put them in if you put them in it makes it harder. No
Yeah, we're leaving them out here. Just gather them and then drop them in there nearby
You're too efficient
Harling
I'm reloading that's what five cans right. I'm gonna go get
I think that we've horde noises over wherever that was
I'll grab that. There's something big stomping around
What? Fuck. Fuck. Oh, yeah
Don't go for me
What there's so many special ones over here
Oh
Jesus
Oh, you grabbed it. Okay. Does this smoke hurt? Oh something's spitting bail and it's not me for once
Yeah, I'll just like burst out of a fucking room. Okay, that bus is killer. Thank you gaming
I'm gonna
Oh, oh no, no
I'm not gonna make it go
Come closer closer
I believe in you
You can do it. I promise you can continue on without me. I couldn't make it in time
Oh, okay, right. I feel better. Thank you for that. Oh, perfect. Nice. Uh
Oh, what the prick girl is another drop or hunter
Oh
The rag doll is great that day. All right, let's find some more. Oh, we'll be all died. Hold on. Where do they die?
I don't know
Tape in the chat. Where are you? I can't see wait wait open the defibrillators
And there'll be a red dot where he is on the map if you have the defibrillators on I do I don't see a red dot
Did you disconnect? Oh, I found him. I found him. I found him. Help. Help. Help. Help. Help. Where are you?
Help. Help. Help. I'm right in front of you
Hold on. Let me look
Right, I'm gonna go pick up more ammo. Very selfishly
I hear a specialist
Spit
Right, I'm gonna go pick up more
Shit, I never thought about that
No
Strutting
Oh my god
Oh my god, I did not just do that too much
I'm so sorry. I can't believe I just said that. All right, at least they respawn. Let's do this
We have to do all of them. I'm so sorry
Right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Lock in lock in lock in. I'm mlg and I want to do
I'm super locking in we're locking in
Right. Fuck it. Just put the cans in the fucking thing because I'm gonna end up doing that again
I can just see it. I honestly can
I think what it was is maybe we were being attacked by a horde
Cuz
Oh
Spray and pray spray and pray pipe bomb
I'm staying next to the AI because they'll cover us
Right there see next. There's a horde coming so prepare if you want to stay next to the AI
Can I'm staying here with the AI and then that horde passes and then we'll go for more
I'm already far away
Oh, no, no, no, no, I can't get you I can't get you. Oh, there's a freaking thing humming me. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on
What is happening? I don't know if I'm helping or making it worse. Hold on. I'm coming. Oh, you're in the smoke. Oh
Fuck yeah, I'll take it. I got you. I got okay. I got you back. I got you back
Oh
No, no, no, I'm reloading I'm reloading
Stay with the AI stay with the AI
This couldn't have gone any worse, I don't have any
Can you see fit him my god, why no, I don't have a defect anymore. It's a one-time
As if it's already out a freaking stone
Okay
Right again, Steve of the AI the AI will protect us. I have a heel for you. Oh
My god, oh my god, oh my god, that's why I'm staying with the AI
Let them do the billet screen here. Oh
No, sorry
Charger
More late
Deader. Yeah, got him
Oh, no, see another horde not I'm not moving out for a can until this is where is it?
I don't
Okay, there we go. Oh, sorry shooting you
Okay, right now we can move out
Oh
My god, why is this so hard?
Right now we can move out for the can as hard I suppose let's move out together all boats rule out. No
What
We got him stay together right stay together like
We gotta get those other cans
Oh, I'm on the wrong side. Oh, wait. No, there's a staircase here. Don't you buddy? There's a wee staircase. I'm on it
I'm coming up the stairs
Okay, then I'm gonna pick up this can and then you pick the can up to and then we'll go right back to the start
And then that's two extra cans
Okay
Oh my god
Okay, okay, no raising no raising no raising. Okay. Oh
Come on
My career is yelling in the background
I
Can't see
Come into the AI come into the AI
Okay, there's something
Okay, let me heal. Let me heal. Let me heal. No
I'm freaking taking
Right, right up you come up you come
Heal and see me right and then I'm gonna heal
this sniper
right and
then
I'm gonna get the fucking can
And put it in the fucking thing. Come here, right
I'm gonna pick up extra ammo
The pills to somebody. I don't know if we're gonna get the pills too. Okay. I picked up ammo. I'm an assault rifle
We need four more cans. I'm fine. I'm fine. Honestly, that didn't hurt that much
Okay, I'm gonna take adrenaline fuck it
Like you actually shove shit in your leg. Oh
My god, something is going on really weird, right? What? Oh, I've took adrenaline. I took a pill and I'd be so I
Didn't
Sometimes we'll throw the NPCs will throw more stuff at us
Wishing they would throw something. Can you guys throw down some like bombs my adrenaline war often now I'm slew again
And there's another word
Right now fucking get back to the AI get back to the AI get back. Yeah, I'm just hanging out with the AI right now
I'm not gonna lie
There's so many. Can you make it replaying? Okay, how are lately? I'm posting. I'm trying so hard. Okay. I'm back in range
I'm back in range. I have a cat that's
Smoker though. We did good. Okay. We did good
We do the smoker. I don't know
Okay, three more three more
Okay, I'm off. I'm off to get another got the high ground and a chance. Oh
Oh
My nose is leaking. Why is it leaking?
Hold on
Shit
Okay, you don't need to find some help
Use me as cannon fodder, right? I've got the next can never
I'm off. I'm gonna fall. I'm gonna follow your back
I'm with the AI. No, no, go with him go with him because I've got the AI covering me now
He has a can he's got he's got the kid
Okay
Charger
How did it get me?
Game and thank God. Oh
Gaming so hard right now one more one freakin more and we're done. We never have to play this level again. Oh
You found heels all across this you see it across this fucking map
I
Literally the very last one. Maybe we oh, maybe you should start with the far away ones
Yeah, bring him closer. Oh shit, okay, we're doing okay. We're doing okay
Okay, we're locked in
No, yeah, not yet. No, yeah, I don't look like over. Oh, you're right. Oh, that's where that's I'm good thing with
I was trying to find that thing. Okay
What oh
Even get out
Okay, okay boomer
All right, that's it. No, right fucking go move out move out move out. No, don't move out. Don't move out. She be
I'm I'm right. I'm fine. I'm the main street. Come the main street. Come the main street. Okay. I'm here. I'm here
No, right, okay, it really is you need to take the one for this the way
Okay, remember we can shoot through each other
I'm getting it. I'm getting I'm getting it. I've got it. I've got it. I've got it
I'm fucking beating up a zombie with it, but I got it. It's fine. It's fine. I'm beating up everything
I'm making my way down to
you
We're not playing this map again. I'm not playing this map again. I'm not playing it again
You
Literally I refuse the bridge
I'm
Please don't make me the last one
It cannot come it's small means cannot comprehend a chain link fence
We're not playing this again
We just got lost Ronnie just left us
Left three dead
Literally that was not
The passing because we all died deceased deceased
Oh, I'm so sorry the soul survivor. I'm not playing that
That was horrible. That was so hard for no reason
So so hard
Yeah, I didn't want to play that again, so honestly
You're actually playing this level again later. No, no
Before we're doing the 4v4 shenanigans. Okay, I can right-click to shove. I know
Will I use it? No
Exactly you tell him
Hey, no, we will now do the 4v4 thing
I don't know what it is
So you're gonna have to tell me how to get into overall accuracy as if I have the highest accuracy
15% let's go
1000 zombies killed wow
So close never end them
Then my game just crashed no, okay, right I just heard and then that was it right, okay
Let us analyze
So if I want to do this 4v4 thing, I would like to
Bye guys, thanks for playing. Thank you very much for playing
Versus it's
Versus
Versus play as a survivor infected in an online match. Okay play with friends
Yes
Play on Steam group server. No, play with friends
Create a new versus lobby like a left-click to gun. Thanks guys
And
Then
Wait we stop you trying to win the campaign
Yeah, we got to try to kill him I want to be a zombie
Right don't bomb yet not until sheepsters is in that's not fair let sheepsters come in I said don't bomb it
Where are you I'm in oh, okay, right?
Right and if you did play previously, please don't do the honor system
Right, so let me write down the names. No one special
That's not a nice thing to call yourself. You should be very special. I know I need to be careful with your words
Cuz you'll start thinking it's true. If you put it into existence, you start willing it, okay?
Noob Lord John on
Battler battler. Yeah battler
And
Right, okay
Right so choose character
Can you guys pick if you're the goodie or the baddie wait, what do you want me and she she be what do you want to be?
I want to be a zombie. Yeah, right. I'm gonna pick
Coach put me in coach right and then can you guys choose character or Danny choose character for you?
I
Can be infected
Okay, if you select infected you do that just do
And then whoever's left will get randomized assume when we start the game
Can I go for a very quick tinkle
I'll keep you occupied. Yes. Give me a moment. Oh, please
Literally not toilets right there
She's she just peas it's like a little
Cuddlefish litter box. Yay
I want to be quiet. I'm trying to hear strong EP
I don't hear anything this is a bummer
I can't wait to be a zombie
You mean my mouth
She be coming to get the hire links. Yep
She being Harlow's versus strong here for people if you guys watch both of us, so
Three gas like no, you guys that to me all the time. I hate it
It freaks me out
So, how are you guys doing?
Hello, welcome in we're playing left for that. I'm sorry. I'm a little bit quiet and low energy
Because of my head hort
Exactly boomy I don't know if you guys heard boomy in the background Justin. Hi. What's up boomy?
Oh
My confirm two steps ahead
Hello, mr. Boomer team had improving at all. No, and I don't know why
We shop you're just here cuz there's food on my desk
Boomy try to steal my mozzarella sticks boomy you can't have this food
Not to get political or anything, but the amount of piss that just came out me I
Was trying to listen. I was listening real close
I was like everybody should be able to hear her
Right, what's the agenda nation?
I think a gender nation
Not being the peolar allegations as soon as the sir it does that I'm dropping mine and then you can all
You can put a compilation of all our peas together. Yeah
You just listen to it on repeat instead of listening to a like one hour of rain to put yourself to sleep
It's just one hour
That'd be a good idea
Loop our piss sounds come on
And we put it up as a freebie on everybody's patreon. Come on
No, you're actually not
You're literally put on YouTube strangely enough, right?
Assume if a hit start game is gonna do the right. It's gonna randomize the rest. So if the other
Snipers aren't bothered. We'll just jump right into it and let's get started now, obviously
First things first everyone but unexpectedly based I'm so based
Someone make a remix of the audios what you want to dance and listen to a song of our tinkles getting
Oh guess the piss so you have to guess who's peeing
Vine one that comes up fine if we do veal or game so I'm fucking doing that kind of content
We're asking you guys about the content that all the Germans was made to play
Love you're really good. Billy. Can you identify who's tinkle? This is?
That would be an absolutely. Oh sounds like Frank chicken. That's definitely strong. Oh
damn
Oh
I have
Okay, so I have me
Have to choose a spawn location ready for this. I don't so you can come at me. Oh
This is
So are you just like a regular schmagular zombie or
Sure peo stream guess there wait peo guest or stream. That's a good. Sorry. I miss all dumb bastards
They thought they could
I'm just coughing the entire time
Why do I cough so much I
Can hear them
We're coming for ya. Oh, yeah, actually
So how can I tell who it is?
Can't walk through this. Oh, I think it's a wall
Come close. I can literally hear something grumbling the woods
Is that you she be are you lurking around? No, are you grumbling? I?
Hear oh
So you have to please fish like zombies against us. Oh my god
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Okay, I'll leave this
Right, it's fun. I just grabbed you with my little fun
Grabbing Harlow, it's your tongue. Are you reloading can't believe it?
Oh
Gosh, what did I spawn is oh?
Is it like randomized zombie spawn as well? Yeah, it seems so. Oh
I'm getting spit on so his spit on me. I don't know what one is but knock it off
I can't see anything. I literally cannot see a damn thing. It's green. Oh
I'm getting my ass. I'm getting my ass. Holy shit. Oh, I can climb stuff
What I'm getting I hate shotgun
I died no way
Have we killed any of them?
Well, I suppose
Isn't it supposed to be balanced like MPP balance, I don't know
We hate the Shrek vision honestly, welcome to
The survivors oh, we have to like stop you oh from like moving forward. Oh, yeah, cuz I recognize this from the
Okay, get boomer bail. Oh
Hold on I'm going to MP
I'm gonna be seen by the survivors
I see that. Who's that? Is that what he is? Oh, yeah, I saw you clear. I saw you creeping around
Oh, no, you got me you got me. I don't know who that is, but you fucking got me
I
You have very low HP, but I suppose cuz you can keep coming back together. Yeah, that's true. I
Can't see shit. I cannot see a single thing. I'm just happy to be here
This is really fun. I like being an evil romby evil
I can't believe it
Watching
The teammates try to kill you guys. That's kind of funny
Like they're lurking around. I guess I don't know what you see, but I'll try. I'll be in it
I'll be an evil zombie next one just so I can see what it looks like
Oh, no, wait, sorry. I thought that was a real I thought that was a real player
It was just a regular zombie. Ah, I hear you
Oh, no, I hear you. I hear you. Hold on. I'm reloading. I'm reloading
Oh, no, I'm gonna die
Can I go faster? What is this?
Hunter sucks
You want to watch where you keep?
Uh
Hold on. I'm reloading
Get a second pistol away
Oh
He must hang himself entering spawn mode. What am I?
Okay, I'm a spitter there's a witch up here. There's a witness. All right
Does it get removed because we're playing versus mode?
I'm trying to find a good place to spawn
Call me Lara Croft because god damn I got jubilee pistol. It's really cool
Oh, I take the whole
You're just lurking in the I can't see anything. Oh, this kills me
Thank god I have to wait for my primary attack to come back
Well, you just stand in there taking all the shots. Yeah, I was just like come on
Why am I trying spitting on you guys again? I like the spitter
I'm hot too and I'm hot too and on you. We can't hurt each other, right?
I don't think so because it's on easy mode. Uh, there's temporary health here
Oh
Watch it put me in coach put me in
Oh the witch. Oh, this is a hard one to be as
But I'll make it work
Yeah, we're gonna we're just we're just gonna pop
Oh, I can't spawn here. Damn it
You guys are so close. We can't even fucking spawn
Wait, it's not it doesn't let you spawn. Yeah, because you guys are right next to us. Oh, wow
Oh, I'm getting fucking shagged. I'm gonna lie. I can't see a single fucking thing going on
I wish I was a I hope I spawn back in as a boomer
Oh, right, let's get a kamikaze myself in the room. This is terrible
Yes
I've seen people dress up in a suit and put a bulk cap on and I'm like, honestly, that's really good. I like that
Where are they they're they're gonna be in their bushes
They're lurking in their bushes. I can't get I'm stuck
Oh, fuck
Fucking humping me god damn little face crawler little face hugger
Yeah, I was being a little goblin take ten killers for temporary health
That'll hold me. We're in trouble. I'm not gonna lie. We're in trouble you guys
May be able to do this. We are not in very good shape right now. What's up on this hill?
Oh perfect
We are very poor right now
I love this part of the map
Well better than that
Can I be seen where did we go?
We have to claim we'll go down the hill. Yep, yes
I'm fucking spraying and praying
Oh, damn it. They saw me
Is it frustrating if we like instantly kill you
That's a little bit. Yeah, I was gonna I was gonna say, uh, uh, probably you're gonna hear me screaming in the next round
Are we supposed to be able to like to kill you all at the same time and then we know
So our health is definitely getting low like don't think you're not doing anything like we're getting fucked up over here
We've not had any heals. So please don't
What was your plan?
Oh, they're cut. Yeah. Yeah
Well, we didn't want I'm getting fucking shocked
No, I'm not gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it. Oh, I'm not gonna make it. I'm getting fucking. Oh my god. We're done. We're all done
I think we're all done. No way. No way
I got her. I got Johnny
We need to feel so badly, but
Get out, literally we are so down. Oh, perfect
It's so hard to find a way where it plays to spawn
Just pray
I'm spraying because you guys are spraying
Are you real?
Up here
Okay, I'm gonna shoot far away
Oh frick, I thought that's my teammate. There's a spatter. There's a spatter six o'clock done the hill
No, no, there isn't is that you
Eat creeping around and get a little green tongue back there
Oh
Please oh, I can't take any more. I'm done
Run to the end run to the end
I'm trying run you're to run to the end you're to run to the end
Go on with that one. No, no, no, no, no, no, you did it. Oh my god
What?
Oh my god, that was the end of the map. Oh, it's so good
No way that was the end of the map. Yeah, you guys are so close
That was so so good my evil laugh
Okay, right, we're gonna back out to give other people a chance
Wait, can you guys leave and like get snipe?
There's him or do you want we I don't know. I feel like both ways are gonna take too long
Yeah, I think I'll take too long. Um, can you guys leave and then others can try and come in?
I don't know see who play
He just said to play with you
Thank you very much gg's
Thank you all. Okay. Yeah, they're leaving. Thank you
Oh, and I sweat yeah
then
how
So you guys can still snipe or do you need to be in the lobby? I don't know
Can anyone see something?
Can't spawn here. Oh wait, hold on. Oh, no, no, it's working as whoa
Got hikaru and stash and okay. Okay. Okay. This is the thing. Okay. Good. Good. Good. I'm waiting on and I got blank
I've got quiet voice
I've got zero
I got blank a blank name. There's no name stash and hikaru
I've got a slot for wait. There's someone without a name. Yeah, literally no name. Whoa
Uh, I guess we'll call you peaches puke because it looks like peaches
So
All right, let's let's move up move up gentlemen
Oh, oh, they just freaking came out of nowhere. Can't spawn here can't be seen by survivors
primary attack
What this is bizarre
Oh what
Okay, I understand. I am I comprehend what we should do
Look the trick is to use snipers. Really? I feel like snipers are so hard to deal with
I'll probably just spot them from farther away
Just like there's not that much in the chamber
All right, so I need to back away
Am I in
I didn't know no, I knocked them down, but I never killed
But I was just like I'm creeping around jump jump. I look like a little leap pro going left and right
I'm like, yeah, my pinks protecting me. You can't shoot me
I'm stuck
Oh, my ping is literally I am lagging so hard. Honestly, it's a what characters live
Leap. Oh, right. Okay. I've got the same one again
I
Can hear one of them
That's so cute
I'm coming for you
Oh my god, that's so good. I was like jumping like a horse or like a frog down there coming to get you. Oh, what the hell?
This is a shotgun set. Oh, it definitely counts one here
Oh my god, the lag is killing me
Oh
I screamed my vomit, but I couldn't really oh no
That boomers are quite hard to play. I'm not sure they're the most effective. Yeah, you literally just have to run
Everybody your bomb gets on them. No, don't bomb every plane. Okay. Mommy's the place
Pute clings rejoice the boomers rage range. Oh, no, this is a tough. Oh, thank you for the heels
Oh
Can't spawn here can be seen by survivors. No, look I fell. No, I can't get up back up there
Oh, no, I kind of know how to get back up there to get to him
Ah sugar may stop one off. I got confused. I thought of is the other zombie
Oh
Oh, someone's getting dead to me down there
Oh, that's me. Oh, no, I will I know I'm supposed to be on there. I might die sooner than the other guys
I'm supposed to be on the enemy team, but I want you to have fun though. I don't want it to be like
Oh, you say you want to play with us?
You
You want to make us laugh a little bit for your amusement
I just want you to have fun like I don't want it to be like oh, we're getting overwhelmed type fun
Oh, no, but that is the part of the fun
Play with your food honestly
Getting a few licks in this is a jockey. It's the jobby
Oh
Oh, there's a witch careful
Don't wake her up. I don't know where she is. I couldn't figure out what one she was gonna get. Oh, we're we're stash power
Somebody oh, he's okay. He's fine. Everybody hung down and claw
Oh charger
I got you
Oh
Tough prick. Oh my god
Is there is there okay pills
Someone's limping. Someone doesn't feel good. Get away from me
The um
I
Love the tongue snarl. Do you have I know it's great. Oh, I see someone coming. I see someone coming
Mommy with a smoker if you tongue someone from a ledge, you can hang them and kill them. Oh
Yep
Okay, we gotta go through the freaking you should you should totally wake up the witch
I'm down
It's like the worst part to be charge and claw
I literally came I let me spawn in the bathroom because you weren't yeah, because I turned her
Oh, shit
Oh, no. Oh my god
Uh
Yeah, I was gonna I didn't want to ruin the fun, but
He's dying in from the wind
I can't get down
Oh my god
Can't spawn here. Something is blocking. Oh, I'm stuck
Oh, no glitched out
I can't see
That fire. Oh my god
I'm good destroyed. I'm coming. I'm calling you. No, I'm done
It's hard. Yeah, that was good
Ah
I'm afraid of screaming about hold on. That was fun. That was good. That was so good. Do you have more for it?
Uh, right, we'll do new lobby. You will play survivors in the next chapter. No, don't put me in the next chapter
We're safe for now. Yeah
Everyone does so well. Thank you. Right. I'm going to
Hey, check it out, man. Are we still in?
Great. For those of you that please please swap out. Uh, you can add me on steam on your scrawny's tank
Oh
Unless we're already on the honor system there's every no, there's a few people that have not had a shot yet. You just snake me in the
Mustache
What is making that noise
There's something
Ah
I'm doing it
Yeah, okay. Sorry. No, you're fine. I walked away. No, no, no, you're fine. You're fine. Uh, right. We have
I got diddy head empty. No thoughts and wisen
I'm just waiting
This is a restricted area
Come on. Leave leave the room
I'm right at the name
I need to be nice and make sure that everyone gets a chance that one gets a chance
Uh, I don't want to show it again. Take the med kit though. Right. Let's do it. Let's do it. Let's do it
All right, they're coming. I don't know where they're coming, but they're coming. All right
They're there. They're there. Someone's here. Someone's here
That's a horde is hard enough to try and win against like the regular ones
I'm being grabbed
How dare you release me
Really?
This person took a long time to kill me
Hi serenity. You're on the roof. Serenity's in your chat room. Hi serenity. Lord, they're coming. Serenity
Did you know about the hit video game left for dead too? It's a really good game
It's a really good game. I get to play for the first time today with shivy
And the reeflings in the harlot. It is such a good game. I cannot recommend it on us
I hope you're doing a fun fun well
It's your first time. Yeah, I've never played it before
And until today and now I forever have the
The loving memory that I got to play this game for the first time with shivy
As I almost kill somebody something's jumping about sorry
I'm watching those movies. Hi serenity. She's on my channel
Yeah, this is really fun. This would be good for like a big collab. Oh my god. Yes. Oh my god. Yes
Actually, it could be 3v3
You
Okay, all right, they were trained well they're trained well
Oh, there's a chain song to go. Oh enemies enemies enemies enemies hold on
There's a spare. Where's the chains?
Yeah
I love being like I can't see nothing. Oh, I'm getting I'm getting
Back off right. I don't like this one because it's not a wreck. It's a burst fire. We don't like burst firing
We want to be able to perish all in
Next viewer collab is left for dead. No, it's gonna be uh, I know what I'm asking for my next viewer collab because
Yeah, I think it's totally not gonna be this game at all
It'll be it'll be gary's mod first and then
Sorry, I still can't figure it where the breakfast chain killer is chain solve killer thingy mobile. We're change. We're change
I'm trying to do my primary attack. It's not working
That doesn't make any sense to me. I can't leap
It's funny because you can see the silhouettes of your teammates and like in
And you can I can see how close they are to you, but you guys don't know about it
Oh, you're really injured. No one has a head cut. Uh
Can't kiss we can you heal? Um her I don't know how you're in character
You have a mental in your person
So I stand still. Where are you going?
Come get healed
No, you come there. Okay this
Oh
What is going on? Oh, I need to see
No, no, stop it. I'll set up up look up look up
Bear on the roof bear on the roof
I was hoping I get a smoker to do that
Don't
Oh
This is hard. This is not easy. Thanks. Now it's your turn to bark
You guys keep getting pulled out. I got rid
What is going on? Hold on. I'm reloading
Oh, my god, we're not gonna make it. We are not gonna make it. We are not gonna make it. I'm sorry. They got me
Uh, there's no way absolutely no way we're gonna make it out alive. I'm one HP. I'm literally limping
I can use adrenaline. Fuck it. Give me that shit. Oh
Oh, perfect. It's like changing. Oh, I'm freaking
That goes wrong. No, fuck that rail. Let's make it. Let's make it 25 percent of the way at least how about that deal?
We'll make it to at least 25
Avoid the gas. Uh, I'm in it. I'm in it. Oh
I killed the bale the bale's getting oh, I have to wait to get my attack back
No, no, no, no, stop hanging us off the ledge. You guys are getting far too good at this game far too fast. No
You got you you freaking got me from the bale
I spell help
Oh
I can't believe it. Let's go
Okay, let's see if we can get farther. Good luck everyone. Good luck. Thank you for
I'm scared. Good luck. Good luck. Let me check this
I'll bag you up on that hell of a show
Okay, uh
We'll get new cleared and no it's tab I want to do
New players new players go go go you miss stream snake at will
My stream snake account is just called scrawny snakes
Got them rabies
You got them rabies, man. I'm getting good at this. I'm I'm in my element. I'm a creature
Creature of the night
Yeah, except now I'm just a
I'm a black woman again
Okay, I got goddamn rabies a keks and alivias alivivis
I love you
Oh my god, look at aliviva's profile picture on steam
Can you see it in the tab?
It's fucking Ryan Goslin. Oh, that's so cute. Is this with you?
Yeah
There's a harem that has a you as a noodle
No
No, I didn't
That's so cute. Are you ready?
Let's go. Let's just do this voice
We got this voice show them no mercy. We can't spawn
Yeah, no, you can't spawn in here. No, no, like it says because you've got POV when you're like
Oh
Oh, he's gonna look behind us because you guys like to spawn behind us. Oh, there you are
Drywall buncher
What a very specific name
Yeah
I made an oopsie
Well, you made a oopsie. Oopsie. Oh, uh
Uh, what am I a pun hunter? Okay, I can do that guns here. Yeah, the ping is kind of trash. Yeah. I mean
Can I wait can I say let me try with the hunting rifle? Oh, what what's happening here?
We're ganging up on you
No
I'm coming for you Ryan Goslin. I've got Ryan. I've got Ryan Goslin. He's over there. Oh, I forgot I can't scope in
I
Got him
I've got I have to do this to scope. That's so weird and now we need to jump she
No, you don't I'm coming. I see you
Get away from me. I'm touching you right now in shadow. No
I'm waiting. I'm waiting to get jumped. Oh, no
You go
Instantly you go protect it. How do you
Incendiary ammo the survivors have made it 25
Come on zombies. We must up every game
Uh, make sure you look up top
Oh, yeah, and keep some creeping around up there coming for you. Yeah
Oh, you should look behind yourself right now. You'll never guess. I'm scared. Oh, they're coming behind behind
Doing fucking call outs
I'm touching you I was touching your hair your shoulder getting your little shoulder massage right there
Oh
What
I was killed by draw I almost got my driver all muncher
Oh, he's getting further than us. Oh, no, come on. We must we must upper game. We must evil zombie think evil think evil evil evil
No, I can't no I can't do anything
I did one spit and I was out. I was gone. Yeah, you have to wait for it to the cool down
I can't believe it doesn't just let you spit all the time
oh
shum
I'm like creeping around. Oh someone's limping
We need to pick off the weakest one first. Okay, there's a grenade launcher though
Tongue snarl
Oh
Which way do we go this way?
Can you guys slow down? I spawned at a really bad location
These are going too fast for me. Hold on a minute
I'm probably gonna
Like native me that was like a nature
She's so motive
Oh
Frick
Can I reload faster?
Okay, I should probably stay with oh, how do I go up? You guys make it up going up. It's so easy
Ah
I don't know
What's the rate they're up?
I see them up. How do I go up?
You know
I feel like
I can't get the jockey I like take on you so easily. Oh the freaking horde
I can see myself. I think yous are almost there. I think you're 50% actually there
You may be able to do it. You're not too down. I don't know you're a bit damaged, but
I think it's the actual normal mpc zombies or what's really getting us
Everyone looks green on mine. Maybe it's not showing your health. No, yeah
No, it doesn't show it like because I'm I'm really close to death right now. Oh, right. Okay. I take it. Sorry
I'm probably you thought I was being real
No, yeah, when you're the monster you can't really see the accuracy of the health
Oh my god
Okay already dead
They all ganged up on us at the same fucking time. We were waiting to spawn. It's like a really awkward location
I'm such a bleed. I don't have anything to fucking throw. I'm almost out of ammo
This struggle snuggle. Yeah, you want the struggle snuggle? I'll give it you
Oh, somebody have any anybody got help. Oh, thanks, brother
Oh, what the
Right in the fucking coochie
Thank you, thank you so much, I appreciate that
I
They all waited
They fucking waited
Holy whoa
I just slayed that was pretty good. That was pretty good. There was a wall where we could climb up from behind
That was like pure cheatsy doodles. That was like you guys all waited. That was very smart
Are we I'm sharing the same brain said go without us just rod brother run run to the end if you can
Because we're gonna come get you. That was a good ambush. We see you
Oh, no that I think that's it
Okay, blah
Oh, damn
All right, that was my last one
Yes, I'm gonna go lay it down because of my I got a head
Please rest. Thank you so so much. She be the uh genuinely. I was so fun when I say like this
This is so fun and unironically I'm going to carry this your association with this game like for the rest
For the rest of my life because I'll always be like, oh that was the game mean she be played
It's not left for a first collab. It was with the reef legs and the hair
Oh, thank you. So says it all should be. Thank you. I love you so much. I love you so much
Okay, bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye
Um, I'm gonna do a few more rounds. So please don't worry
Please do not worry ladies and the king implement. I'm gonna do a few more rounds. Uh, I 100
percent
I'm going to
Revisit like she be smart should be wrapping up stream. I am 100 percent revisit in this game where we're going to play campaign modes together
a stream snip campaign mode
um
Yes, thank you so much sheepsters
I am going to play another round to make sure that everyone that what that who everyone who wanted to play gets a chance to play
understand
I hope so
So if you have had a shot, please leave if you haven't had a shot, please come in, but i'm like 90 percent sure
I haven't seen these names. Um
But yeah, let me just write down these names
Yeah, I don't remember any of these
Uh, this game. Okay. I don't I hate to be that person
That's like I've heard about that game forever ages. I just never did anything with it
I I get it now. I understand it all. Please forgive me
Could you screenshot the lobby list all like writing it down? I was going to show a collage at a later time of um
All uh the all the stream snip stuff we get to do
Eh, but yeah, her sheepsters have a headache
Um, but she did so uh, honestly fucking tank that she did so well
Uh
See we know what games you would like exactly exactly right um
We'll just go for it
Start voice chat as opposed to not have a watch right
Shoes character edit game setting
dark carnival one two
That was a fair ground right we'll do the coaster now
And then start on the coaster
Start game that looks right. Yeah, that looks right to me
I think it means a lobby voice chat. Oh like it's the same long
As long as you found this game we're happy a little reef land. Yeah
As I said, I'll keep uh going for a wee bit longer. I'll try and get everyone in that wants to play
um
And then uh, I actually to talk a bit more about what work I got done yesterday
Um, I wrote 11 shorts like pre-recorded shorts. Um, I've recorded about
Eight of them one of them needs to be recorded with the ASMR microphone
So tomorrow I'm waking up at midnight
So I can tap on the key chains and do a little hand
A ASMR video
11 shorts is good. I was only supposed to do five but I kept going. Who wants to bark for me?
All right, but keep your hands to yourself
No one you just shy of bark anyone
I think they don't have microphones. I don't know they use have microphone
um
Well, I'm ready when you are I don't have a microphone
All right, let's go
Crouching improves accuracy. Oh, it's like fiasco
Maybe may I ask about playing off the side? I'd like to make fun of the pants
I was just going to do random and make sure everyone gets them before I go off because I'm I'm trying to do
A lot of work for me. Um
Because I've been
Putting a lot off, but I believe I can get the yumi collab up finally today
Um, I think you can get the yumi collab up for tomorrow. Um, I just need to oh god
When is it gonna start respawning? I'm scared
Uh
Over in the tunnel of love
Oh, jeez, where are they are they in oh god, you're all having to play on my ping
I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry the game's like nice and buttery smooth for me your game must be like skating on I
Yes, um, so I won't take up too long today because
It's either like long streams or they're here. They're here
it's either long streams or
In no like other content outside of streams or a wee bit shorter streams
But more content overall like I think
That'll hopefully help I in quotation mark. I'm not sure I just
Ah
No
No, no, no, I can't see
I can't see
But yes, I cannot wait to play the rest of the campaign. I love it. Love it. Love it. Unfortunately
I don't know what the deal is with uh left for dead. Whoa
Stop it. Stop it. Stop it. Stop it. I don't know what the deal is with left for dead one
Um, but I'm very happy to complete the campaign with you. Uh, if you will have me
Um, oh my god, I don't think we're gonna make it. I don't think
I can heal you. I can heal you
I'm gonna heal your ass
Wait, you can heal on top of the heal that I'm doing. That's a whole lot
Well, we'll be playing left for dead another time. Yes, we're gonna play the campaign and finish it together
But yeah, uh, very busy doing shorts and
Oh, we are not gonna make it. Sorry. I'm too busy freaking yapping. I'm far too busy yapping. I need to knock it off
Oh
I'm I'm helping. I'm helping. Oh my god. Everyone's gonna die because of me. I'm so sorry
I'm so fucking sorry. Hold on. Give me this one. Let's don't do that
Tunnel of love, okay, but we're fine. You seem to be okay
Feeling very loved in this tune
Reloading
But short
Sorry
My brain's starting my brain's short so I'm getting right now because I'm trying to think of like, can I see that yet?
And it's like, no, I can't see that yet. I can't see that yet. Um, stop you're all hanging up on me
You stinky
Please I will play for as long as if all four of you's coming at the same time
I thought there's gonna be looking at
Right, I can heal someone I can heal someone. Let me be a medic
Who am I healing?
Are you coming through
Dead meat dead meat more like alive meat when some okay unless you heal yourself
Alive meat when some done with you
Don't be stinkers
Whoa
I just lagged really badly and I'm the whole
What is
No, hold on a minute. No, hold on a minute
what
Stuff's happening to me before my game displays it. You're cheating
Squeak squeak is that what squeak squeak is? It's one of them
I went back in time literally, uh, can it handle this right now? I don't know if it's handling us
Stop billing moment exactly. Oh, I got an ek. I'm happy
Okay, let's just figure out where we have to go right over the spine
Where the enemy's coming yeah, you're 50% of the way there the end of the map at the county valve
Whoa, I'm the horse. How am I lagging?
How am I lagging right I'm to heal someone
Okay, let me heal you
Oh, and there's a horde
I'm the bully mommy when she likes it. Wait, what are we doing?
Deactivate the right. Oh
Your freaking spit and bail is getting me
Stop it. Oh the NPCs are gonna oh no way. I'm down. How much?
Oh
I'm
Where do we go
I don't we go in here we have to go up the train track. Oh, it's not train choo choo
I'm reloading
Oh, I got you I got you. Yep. You got me. I'm shooting you in the dick. Fuck you
I'm spree and I'm spree and it's not happening. It's ogre
I'm freaking laying down cover fire. No, we don't have way. Oh wow you go really close the one who went ahead gg
Mummy's getting founded
I'm pickable timing on the charger get ruled by that
That's hard
The left for dead mission are this game's dlc, which is why there's so many maps in the game
So there's no need to play the first game, which is why there are so many maps in this game
So there's no real need to play the first game
Right
Okay, I guess we're gonna have to play again. Thank you very much for gg. Thank you very much
Thank you
Right and then we get new
Again honor system if you have played before get get farted on
You have to you have to
Server shutting down competitive mode requires human players on both teams. Oh
We girl boss too hard
We did it a little bit too hard
Okay, let's we'll do the
um
We girl boss too hard edit game setting
Carnival no carnival and then part four, which is the barns and go back
And then the lobby will fill up with humans
Yes, there will be humans. There'll be lots of them
And I'll make sure everything thank you sash power for the tip as well. I'm so sorry if I missed any
Um, I think I caught everything though. I know you're not supposed to be like, thank you xy lmnop, but
Like I don't know it's sheepsters. I feel a little comfortable. I don't think she's gonna be like
Hey
Akex haven't you had a shot before
Uh
Can you play again? I don't know if everyone's had a shot yet. So not yet. I'll tell you when thank you
Okay, bye. Sorry. No, no, you don't need to say sorry. I'm just making sure
Um
That charger fuck does that room we've done for I just want to make sure in case there's any
Uh, oh wait, can I play the zombies this time?
No, actually, I want to play the humans because I actually don't even know what this thing is
I just want to make sure I've got everyone that wanted to play but we might have done it
That everyone that's active right so many of you appear offline. What's going on?
What you played maga
Calarium never heard of it team fortress to the fix the servers red m never heard of it satisfactory
blade and sorcery don't know that one
And then some of these are online
And some of these are offline shock and behavior shock and behavior
And
Okay, if that's everyone that wants in then yeah, you can stream snipe again. You can come back in
You can come back in I give you permission to come
I didn't get to bark because I got my make yoings honestly
a right duplicates are allowed
Star
Star yes
And then you play dark and when we come back to stream snipe for the game, um
We could go back to the very start if you want to I don't know
I don't I can't remember how many chapters there are if there's 10 was it 10 chapters
Um
It's for me on the other side of a fence as a charge I thought you guys would get away for this kind of a cover
Uh, yeah, we could start from the start and do it that you're with me for the full like chapter
But I feel like that's quite a lot versus like getting swapped out and going again
um
Your connections best you're gonna get kicked out the server. We are loading someone
Joining a versus game starring
Two moves
Not all the fun rules the latino world
There's 14 campaign no reason to do dead center and pass them again
Okay, so we've got we'll be able to wrap up in one stream snipe steam stream
night
That's not a problem at all
and
But if that's everyone then I'm happy to wrap up after this one
And then I'll get to work with my behind the scenes
Hello
How did that open on its own?
I'm on the server horse
Spooky
Spooky what was that?
Is that an in-game voiceline or do one of you just call me sweetheart?
Am I going crazy?
How much did you sleep? I think I got like five
Uh, I'm not really sure what the deal is channeling
I will ah Jesus
They're jumping us. I'm not even fucking going. It's fun yet. Oh my god. I'm not gonna make it
I'm not gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it. Oh my god. They're all picking on me
Stop
No way I'm dead already
Stop wait. Let me go back in that room. Let me go back in that room. There must be a gun in here that I need
Oh my god, right get at least put that on right. I'm healing myself up. I can't believe I'm such an idiot
I hear you creeping around on the roof
I hear you creeping around you're getting ready to jump me
Okay, like let's do it. Let's do it push push push
We have to push through or else we're gonna get new
Oh
I love this shotgun come through come come come together together. Don't don't keep coming keep coming keep coming
Right together keep going keep going keep going egg baking grits sausage keep going keep going keep going keep going keep going
Move move move go grease landing. We're burning up the quarter
Because they're gonna spawn I don't know where
They're coming though
Okay, come come come up up up into the little pit thing
The ping is hitting different. Yeah, you think the ping's a little bit spicy
I'm sorry about that. Yeah, you think it's just a wee bit spicy
I don't know. I don't think 306 ping is that bad honestly
No, I don't really see what the problem is in a multiplayer game that requires fast reaction time and wits and all of that
Yeah, no, I don't think it's that bad
Oh
Is there a chopper? There is
I'm reloading
Bump bump bump bump bump bump. We're down already
Don't you spit on me. I heard that
I heard you do that. Oh my god. You spit on me while i'm down naughty
Bad bad get purged get purged get purged get purged
No way. No way we hardly got anywhere
We suck
We got no way. We didn't even make it to the 25% mark
Oh that was terrible that was terrible
Will we do a swap out?
Or will we continue that fell a bit rough?
I've done that fell a bit rough for the first players. I think maybe stay in
And then we'll finish this up since we're at the point where everyone's had to grow
So yeah, just stay just stay just stay. Yeah continue. Don't don't leave. Don't swap out
Oh, we're waiting on you. We're waiting on you to get out that room. I dare you
Mmm, I do I'm sorry
Oh, don't be sorry
What if I press e it like tracks me onto a new player, okay
They got lucky with that tank enemy team knows what they're doing. It's gonna be rough. We'll find out. We'll find out
My name is strani cuttles and I will have my revenge
Mummy tanks can hit objects at instakill. I didn't hear me
Okay, we're ready
We're ready. They just need to open the door
Open the door open the door
Open the door
Come on. We're waiting
What is it?
Come on
No, wait, how did you are you stream sniping?
You're not supposed to stream snipe like that. You're only supposed to stream snipe the other way where you come on stream with me
You're not supposed to actually stream snipe my position
Don't cheesy doodle
That's cheesy doodlin
Yes
No way, they're gonna win so easily
Charge
Oh my god, it doesn't have accuracy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, your mom
Ah, no, I don't have the HP. Okay. I did a few bits of hits. Okay
It's a few bits. It's like they can hear you or something. They're in the walls. How did they know?
Bro's head and perfect be hops is over
Wait, are we actually against like mlg pro?
No way
We can't see your health bar. It's really hard
Oh, oh
Absolutely rule
Okay, come
Wait, we've overwhelmed them really great at the exact same position as well
Yeah
Okay
Wait, why is this map so hard both sides couldn't do it
It must be a difficult map. There's no way
Wait, oh, no, they're still up. No, you can't
Whoa
It must be a really hard part of the map
All right, well, we read some marshy malons. We do some marshy malons. They won by eight points. No, fuck you
Most damage to tank. No, no, no, no, no more no more exit to mean menu. Uh, yes, that's okay
Um, yeah, I've read some marshmallows before I wrap up for a rapidly
Uh, right. How does
Usually the last click
Manage
Remover's friend. Okay friend removal time. Yes. Yes. Okay. I'm doing the friend removal. You can watch me do it manage
remove his friend remove his friend
manage
remove
Manage
Oh, right. Okay. Wait, we'll start with the people who are offline. How about that?
Remove as friend. Oh, this is gonna take forever. This is what I do when I hate this screen
And it takes forever for me to do it at the end, but it's worth it because I get to play with you
Like
Remove as friend. Yes. I'm gonna end up accidentally blocking someone. I was so really bad remove his friend
Isn't there an easier name? No, this was the easier way
This is the easier way. It takes me longer
Sorry, mama. I got you earlier because I heard your character gurgling
Love you
Love you too. We blend. I hope you had fun
Next time we're all going to be on the same team. So there's no evilness that bay between
Either party. There's no evilness. There's no we're all trying to win
I'm gonna enjoy the
aim
Experience that is lifted to I can't believe like I've managed to like
Not avoid the game, but like it just never happened, but um
Not to get sapphie as I said like no, I'm always gonna associate it with sheepsters and
you reflain and
they
as well as um
All panoramic sunroof. Thank you for the five gifted memberships and congrats to those who caught it with your face
aim
That's right get get emoticon. Oh, yeah, it's your birthday. Oh, yeah
It's your birthday. Oh, yeah
Right, how do I fucking?
Right
Manage remove his friend. My brain cannot do two things at once. I'll read some marshy mallows before I go
Obviously, um
I'm gonna have to investigate the in me situation a bit more
Uh
If you see that
You know ASMR is deleted and all that. Please don't be surprised
Yeah, you enjoyed it. Well, I'll see about it wrapping it up this month
I think I'll swap out a boring game and then we'll do a full day stream sniping on this game. Um
Not that the games I pick are born not to say anything about the other games. Um, but
How the fuck
Right
Thank you. I leave you vast as well for the tip. Um, no, I'm glad you had fun. Well
Dude, that is a really good stream snip game. Obviously elden ring was a big stream snip game
but that came with a hefty fucking price tag like that was
um
like a big
Price tag that came with that one
Um, uh, whereas I think life for dead. I'm gonna hope that it's cheaper, right?
Surely surely life for dead in general is cheaper, right?
Right
Because it's so old
and ancient
Okay
She has the um
Oh
Did emmy say
Okay, if emmy said it then
I am very
on tentative hooks
Right now. Um, I am very
To put a long story short
We were getting prepared to create a new account
It's like three dollars on sale. Okay. There you go. Yeah, she tweeted. Okay to put a long story short
Uh, we were getting prepared to create a new account. So that was very surprised
How does it
Um
But
Obviously I am over the moon at the result. I'm just very surprised
Because of some other stuff, but I mean fuck who am I? Fuck it. I'm joining you on team fortress too
Uh, manage remove his friend
Manage remove his friend
And then okay, let me just check that no one's like
There's not like anything that could hate it or anything like that. Yeah
What's fun facing the zombie apocalypse with you. Yeah
It's over. It's absolutely over for us
We're goners
Thank you reluctantly saying for the tip
Emmy prayers came true. I had a good feel in her channel would return emmy showing everyone why she's a necromancer
and raising herself from the dead
Well, emmy is the god damn magical ties
Is
Is that what the panic was at the start of the stream? I did not know emmy's account was restored
I basically ran through to my other pc and deleted all of her asmr content. Um
And what will happen is once there's no strike on her channel
I'm sure she will agree to this. I'm sure the pin pals are more than happy. How the fuck did you do that?
Oh
How did that did I know how did you do that? How did that work? What happened?
Uh, thank you colker for the 10 gifted memberships as well. Congrats. So there's a cut over your face. Please enjoy them
Hey, all that thing just don't stand in front of mommy when she's covered in bail
Uh, she shoots everything. Yeah, basically. Was the internet possible?
I'm green as a big bro. I'm really happy. Yes. I am bloody happy too
I forgot to mention the game has a special aspect each special
In fact, it has its own creepy musical tune if you can't see them or hear them the tune kind of gives them a
Oh, I've got the music like turned way down in my head. So I'm so sorry. I probably missed that
This game has a special aspect to it
Each special infected has its own creepy musical tune if you can't see them or hear them
The tune kind of gives them away
Like I said, youtube did a system restore a week ago and some channels got revived again
YouTube just crashed and reversed the code. That doesn't explain why the rat strike was removed. So youtube denied it
which is
I um
I am very I am nervous
I'm nervous
I still have you as a friend on the chosen one. How have I not?
Can you unfriend me? How do I like
Open up your profile and unfriend you
I don't get it. I can't see you
I
What the fuck I don't know how you're doing get the fucking I don't know how you're doing that
Thank you for not sending a really inappropriate message because that could have gone fucking crazy. Right. So does that mean
Is that I still says friend play in?
No, right, okay, it's gone. There we go
YouTube felt the power of grace and realized we're wrong quite and check again. Yeah, it looks like that's everyone now
I thank you for not putting something wildly inappropriate because uh, yeah
No, I'm not adding any more. No
Nope, you don't
No stream snake. There's no game. We're not playing game
uh
Yes, I
I don't want to celebrate prematurely. I don't know why the rat sniff was removed
and
obviously when we realized the account was up, obviously fucking shivy was being chaining and I fucking ran through to
delete all of the ASMR real quick
um
I suspect someone so
If we're if we want if we want to talk about it, I'm happy to talk about it
Amy I
asked Amy
When that rap band first happened to please reach out to youtube on twitter and I told her what to put and she did it
Um, but we never got help because she never did the appeal at that point
But it got denied and then she never asked for further help. I'm wondering if that
some
how
kicked in because of the server reset thing
And it did get taken off even though on twitter they were like not worth anything at all
Um, I just don't want to celebrate prematurely
But as I said all the ASMR has been removed. Everything else is above board. Um
As far as I can tell and
Once that warning is gone. I'm more than happy for her to do ASMRs again
I am not for baiting before anyone's like you're for baiting a talent to do one thing but everyone else can do the other
Motherfucker, please be realistic the account just got taken away. We've been giving it back. This is our second chance
Do not fuck up that second chance
um
I
I'm very happy that the account is back, but I I just I don't think I'll feel
secure until like a couple of weeks have passed and all honestly, you know
Uh, maybe maybe our payment. I mean shit. Can you do memberships again? Hold on a minute. Can you do memberships?
Or does it need to be re-enabled again?
Oh, that's scary her profile picture doesn't load for me when I straight when I search my name. No the join button's back
What
The thumbnail for her 30k celebration screen isn't loading for me. What's that mean?
Oh
What does it mean? I don't know
Why is her stream chained together? I just farted and it smells like eggs. Why would you call it that?
And then why would you call it that?
I'm a member so it's okay membership is back
That's a good sign. All right. That's a immaculately good sign
Oh reeflings, I can't believe that hold on speaking of smelling eggs
That was the world's quietest egg
Management here. What oh for fuck's sake. I thought you were in me management for your her
Her channel is fully functional and monetization is enabled
Skin walking is emmy discussed and go here. Don't ever type in this chat again unless you are the real
Mab soup someone called her b soup and I absolutely loved it
Okay, thank you management. I appreciate that that
As I said, I still feel very tentative. I'm like, I mean, but if the strike isn't there
Them's the facts. The strike is no longer there. So thems is the facts
You know
Uh rushy roue rushy roue. I'm so sorry rushy roue
Ryu
Thank you for the membership. Hope you enjoyed that most my sister became a bro. Nice. No, don't celebrate
Don't celebrate that in her
Don't celebrate skin walking
Right, okay, let's get right into the news
You should either revise the AI. That's what my brain is now thinking why they had to resort to turn code
Is the AI filter?
That's what my brain is currently trying to calibrate and say is that logical to assume
They might have tried to update the AI filter recently that um watches over the content
She still has a six day wait. However before she can stream upload and post
So that's acting like a strike one
So there is no official strike two anymore. She's just a straight one. What the fuck is going on?
I'll do some invest in my gating. Thank you management. I'll do some invest in my gating
So there's now no strike two on emmy and it's now now the
The collab a some arm video has been treated like her strike one
That's bizarre. So the gummy worms are now her official strike the rats breathing in the mic are not the strike
A six day wait is better than 13. It's a hell of a lot better than fucking rebuilding as well
I think we can all celebrate that one my darlin
My darlin riflin. I think we can all celebrate a six day wait
Uh
Wow, that is very curious
is it
As I said, I'm trying to just not get too in over my head and celebrate because I
That I just don't understand what on earth
changed
Twitter's youtube support on twitter said not the rat breathing. It's still getting a strike
We contacted youtube's partnership chat and they were like we know that this is a rat breathing on the mic
Um, but you're still gonna get a strike because we take all the channel's content into consideration
And it's like no if you're gonna give a strike for something aim it don't just shotgun blast it
Oh, right
You should didn't want to deal with the rat sniffing allegations. Yeah
I
Keep expectations low but hope up. Yes. Sorry. I sorry if I sound so doom and gloomy at the end of this
I'm not doom and gloom. I'm just shocked
Okay
Hey
Um, hello mommy. I wish I had left for dead too so I could join you join and bark for you
Maybe ruflin's, please have some hugs and kisses. Yeah, I can give you kisses
Hmm, are you gonna keep streaming? No, no, don't redirect into me. No, don't redirect into me
I'm out. I'm out. I'm reading marshmallows and I'm out. Don't redirect into me
I'm out very shortly
Uh, I can't give a hug on this microphone because you can't hear it, but I can give kisses
Thank you for working hard
Is a zero
I'm sorry if I didn't bark vigorously enough. No, I have housemates and felt embarrassed. I'll be a good boy and do better
Oh my god, that's so fun. I love you story. I love you too ruflin so glad to play and talk to you. Yeah, it was a fun
Hey, mommy, thanks for playing this game with us ruflin's and she maybe a monthly play for this game
Anyway, there's a lot of tips and tricks you can do in the game like hunter pinball tower punching to instant kill survivor
I'm about to go get off. I was saying about a harem and got caught up. No, no, no, I do that
So let's all have a yeah at the end of a good stream. Yeah, we can have a big yeah
um
Also making 11 shorts. Let's hope one goes viral. That's what I'm hoping as well. Um
Some of them, I think three of them have potential to get a bit of traction. Um
I'm gonna get them all edited before I start uploading them because
If you upload live content like a highlight from a stream, it never does as good
But if you do pre-recorded it does quite well like it's never been seen before
Okay, a new make just to stream for the next time the stream that is so cute
No, you don't have to purchase a new make as long as you can talk through it
So they admit that if you do something wrong once they put a target on you based on past off
I don't it's very hard. So basically
We were asking youtube like hey, can you go one step further and say what's wrong? And they said
We can't tell you because you'll use it to skirt the rules and it was like no motherfucker
We don't know what the rules are you're not telling us
I am
Short and short and short. Thank you for today's stream moment even though you stream quite early for me
Yeah, 4 a.m. Early. I believe that you bring joy to my quiet nights and mornings
I appreciate the things you did for us and your gen mates. Oh darling. I know the fellow reeflings would say the same
I'll hope you take care of yourself. I hope you have a good rest your day to love you. I love you too
I'm so glad you could enjoy it
And I can keep you company
Mommy keep me company
La la la la la la la la la la la. Thank you for the three extended memberships
Three months extended membership three months already. Our baby's flying so big
Skirt the rules you want to know the rule. Yeah, that's what they say
They're like, we're not going to tell you because you're going to skirt the rules and it was like, what are you talking about?
We don't even know what we did wrong. It was a rat sniffing a microphone like at least fucking aim
Aim at something if you're going to give a strike at least aim at something
I know each of her channel got absolutely ruined because their shorts went hyper viral
And that ruined her channel metrics and how the algorithm works
Mm. Monk is starting to enter that
Actually, no, I'm gatekeeping myself. Fuck it. Yeah, fucking obliterate my channel
No, alessandro. Thank you for the extended three months membership
How big what happens what happens at three months of pregnancy to the embryo?
Or is it a fetus? Is it a fetus? Okay, it's a fetus. Sorry
The third month of pregnancy is when an embryo becomes a fetus. Okay, let me change my phrase then
Skin and fingernails begin to grow
Changes triggered by hormones begin to make external sex organs appear
Female or male the fetus begins making spontaneous movement and the kidney starts making urine
So it's filling his lung blood. I'm curious
All things filling with blood
You're at 26,000 subs
Better not be
I've still have a deficit of ASMR. Actually, I'm doing a membership script writing stream
Next month next month next week
I have so much content to discuss with you
Because I need to plan ahead
So that's going to be a big stream. We're all need to put our heads together
Reluctantly saying thank you for growing fingernails for our baby
Um, we say three months of enjoying this glorious goober and the most comfy community creed hell. Yeah, we've been blessed
Amen
Right, congrats on 26k. Thank you
Roondi isolation. Thank you for the extended three month membership
Already three months so much love and laughter shared and hoping for much more of the same in the future. Oh, yeah
Still talking about that ASMR debt, you know
I think I'll be more motivated to make it up when you guys dictate what you want like when you say like I want this
I want that I think I'll be a lot happier. Thank you sleepy phoenix for the uh extended three months
Since I didn't get to ingame bark bark
So are we green now you're always green our theme is green for the green game
Oh
Mummy does this
All the girls will stop to make ASMR or just any
Uh, I think what the policy is that we are enacting a new policy at velour headquarters
Oh, my fellow Americans. Um, I think if there's someone with an active war strike
ASMR is paused if it's someone has an active warning
Then
You know do what you do
Scarecrow damn. Thank you for the three months extended members
Directly
There direct again karma
Why are we fucking supposed to say three months and so much has already happened as reeflings are truly blessed to have your
Love your mummy also bark
We become pink in november, I think
Yeah, you get your new shell
Zero thanks for the three months as well. Is this my monetization date? It must be or else. However, you've become members
I remember
I remember. Thank you zero
Couldn't have asked for anything more love. Yeah. Love you to refland
It's a strong dictatorship literally. Yeah, I'll discuss with the girls what they feel
Um, I know mersi's a bit scared of doing ASMR streams, which adds any bloomers to be honest that the fucking
late night and so on
And there was another vtuber called lea kitty that got a fucking live stream removed because she blew down the make
which
maybe
Maybe these code and things maybe the ai getting changed but it's breaking
And I can't eat some more
Hmm plausible very plausible actually. Um
I wouldn't recommend it for anyone that has a warning. No a a warning or uh strike
Thanks for the game mom. It's it was fun to play left for dead again
It really brings back memories of playing at cyber cafes after school with the homies really you go to cyber cafes
I wonder what it was like
Strony molestia cyber cafes marwin who said that you said that a bit too quick. That was a bit too quick
Gigi strony. Thank you for the game looking forward to those shorts coming out. Yes. I'm looking forward to them
So I'm sending off 10 of them
And then there's one that needs to be recorded on the ASMR microphone
But I can't do it now because the birds are tweeting so no ASMR mic pumping
I wanted to do that so badly
Mmm, I came the one to do it like really fucking bad blue
I was hoping to get a riefling plushie and then I put the microphone in front of your
tentacles and I was gonna record it and
Yeah, I think I'll just straight up make that old twitter content
Isn't your warning gone in a couple of days? Yes, it is
On the 19th, I no longer have a warning and a week later. I'm doing tanga ASMR. I said what I said
I'll be taking no questions. I said what I said and I'm going to try and reupload the clap
because it was just the
Strony gets band speed running after Amy just got her channel back
room
Pumping only one week left
Pumping louder
Hello moma. Thank you for letting me play with you so much when I can't wait till the next left or dead
Yes, we're going to have a full day of left or dead stream sniping
Wait, well the plan was going well soon thought the riefling I'll be able to duck away
He barked but it took
Encouragement the riefling saw Strony watch him with her unusual pupils
Sometimes it seemed
She could see inside him. He loved her very much, but it was a little unnerving to think his thoughts were
Might be laid
Bear so easily
He saw her pupils change and his vision dipped and swam suddenly he was gone
Oh, she suddenly she was gone. Please get some good rest tonight. I will
We love you so much and want you live a good lifestyle
Love them
Thank you so much mb bucket
And thank you for the tip. I promise I'm looking after myself
as I said
I had what was known as a selfish day yesterday and a selfish day means I work on my own content basically
um
Only just got back love you moma. I'll be too
Hey, I'm just reading marshmallows and then we're gonna redirect into a zero
I think I know as there's not up. Yes, you're getting redirected into a stream. That's just shellfish
I'm so shellfish, honestly
um
Saw her pupils change and his vision
Uh dipped and swam suddenly she was gone. He blinked. What happened? Where did she go?
strongy's voice from close practically right next to his ear
Revealing she said in her soft sultry scottish tone
Do you need a little more time on stage to shake your shyness?
He broke out in a cold sweat as her rifle slid towards the cans painstakingly collected
He couldn't move couldn't stop her if he wanted to
I think it can be arranged
I think it can be arranged. She said with a soft chuckle the rifle barked and a plume of flame
Billowed out consuming each in a firework the roar of the fire in her chuckle and said what what is what was that story about?
I
I'm not sure
Uh
You're back you're back you're back
Hi, did you not know I'm back?
Long time no see miss me. I missed you
Is that left for dead to fanfic? I'm not sure what that was
Cause
Causing you to redo the map with a shy refund
Selfish they working on shorts for refunds. You have a funny definition. No, I think it's selfish
If I don't
Like do work for the girls in the background like something they plan something they want. I consider it selfish
Guess who's back back back back again again
strongy's back back back
Tell a friend friend friend. Yes, who's back. Yes, who's back. Yes, who's back. Yes, who's back
Manine
Did the word refling all correct to rifle is the rifle supposed to be the use of this one?
A
Hi, mommy. I think it would be cool if you or the community did some sort of mensman in health awareness charity month third
No, don't say that. I'm loud already have a plan to be quiet refling
You're ruining my plans
You're ruining it
You're ruining my plans refling. There's already something being planned
Stop it. You're ruining the secret. You're not even in fucking management
I'm not even wrote down and told the girls the plan yet. You're ruining it. Stop it
You're ruining it
Can I be so bold to ask on the sass for the twitter pictures? Yes
Yes, I've been such a well behaved inkling. Oh, that's so cute. Yes. Um, I hope to have
Your call their photos up by the end of today
No, I please I do apologize for anyone that waits for anything on the old twitter
I try very hard
But as you can imagine with the situation made me channel yesterday
The last thing I felt like doing was
You know taking off my armor
Um and posing with your caller that was kind of the last thing on my mind. So, um
Wait, you don't have your caller on now. No, you have to tell me if you want it on on streaming
Do you want to start doing that? I mean, I'm down to do that
If we if we start a stream and then you tell me put on a fucking down for that
Ha ha
No worries. We know you're busy. Yes, I'm going to aim to have it done
But if I don't have it done, please no, I'm probably doing a shit ton of stuff
Mommy, how goes the figure delivery? I've not heard any updates from it since what they do is they make it
When to order order. Fuck. Um, they make it to order
Which means that it takes a long time and it's coming from america
Hi
So I have to do that
It might be a while. I think so
I don't know
The tail might arrive faster
Uh
Hi strong
I don't know brine. Are you squinting imperial monarch?
Thank you for the three months extended membership. Happy three months. Also caller now. Fuck. Okay. Shit
G
Fuck me
We're not one chief
There you hear this
Fucking hell that's been taken off the start like the back of it
This is me putting it around my neck
Fuck no
So that fan arc was actually just straight up a previous reel
That artwork was insane that that uv like glow in the dark one. Oh my god. My hair's getting caught in it
Ow, I'm filling my hair. Wait, let me take my headset off
Caller I barely even know her
But it's
Well, I put it on there. Jeez. I'm not very smart
Wouldn't it be cuter if you call it you though? Imagine me looking up at you from the floor
I'm on my hands and looking up at you with a little pup like at the collar
Hmm
Okay, I got it on now you hear it. That's my nails against it
Now bark
You will all get into pet play and it'll be my fault
I don't know brian. Are you squinting me?
ABI
Zarian, thank you for the 300 memberships. Happy three months cut us. Now. That's the collar on part bank
But pant bark for us good little pup
The fan service is insane. Look we cut to the chase over here
You get milked for like
Months and weeks on end by other feature written that I get
Fucking straight to the point. I know why you're here. I know why I'm here. So let's get inkin
Hi staroni. Hi reflin when it comes to talking in game
I don't talk to randoms because 90% of the time is awful. I'm happy to talk to you
I tried to talk in overwatch stream, but I didn't realize my mic was muted. Oh
If you play any games I'll have in the future. I'll bark as much as possible. Love you strudy. Love you too reflin
Well known amiss. Thank you for the extended membership good girl and I come here for scratches
Are you scratches?
II
I got so nervous and excited to play with you. Thank god she be
Fades the fed the cats that you're able to count down your hands were shaking and your heart was pounding. Oh, I'm so sorry
I hope in a fun way. I hope I don't make you nervous. I promise you. I'm not a good gamer
So it's not like I'm gonna like judge your gamer skills or anything like that
I had the same problem in overwatch streams name. Are you getting nervous to play with me? Oh, no
How can I relieve that? I don't know how to relieve that
Oh
I'm so sorry
I don't want to make you scared of me
Hey, you're strong. Sorry. I didn't I didn't bark when I was in game. I got embarrassed. Oh, no
I'm scared. All of you's away
I'm making you so terrified of me. The pressure is real. You want to impress. I'm so sorry reflin
You can't disappoint me. You can't make me upset. I was so sorry. That was another
I like teasing you with a bark
I feel like if one person joins and talks and the others would talk more probably
I can't believe it. Um, oh, I have some people I was more scary or she be and you guys said she be so I was like
Obviously, you should just talk to me then
And then I can get you it's nerve-racking playing with your crush. Oh, that's so fucking cute
Yeah, I'm making nervous
Would be a shame if we had our first sleep over together, huh? And we played video game
And then I instantly sit on your lap without asking and then you wrap your arms around and we both have our controllers in front of us
I think that's how
Imagine getting a voice crack all seen something and oh, no, are you worried about your voice cracking?
Oh, my voice cracks on stream all the time though
Mmm
I couldn't bark because I was on the opposite team. Mmm, what you see
The idea of you hating us is more scary than dying
No
Mummy you're making me imagine stuff that only happened in my dreams
I mean I already have all your addresses
Oh, you thought you thought Marisy was the yandere. No, no, you see
Uh secretly I've been running left for dead through my own piehole servers. It's been logging your ip addresses
I now have all your addresses
Are you didn't are you didn't realize then you don't think it was funny my menu looks slightly different
You thought the ping was 300 because i'm in australia. Oh, no, no, no, no. I have gigabit internet
I assure you I I got the good stuff
I'll leave the door unlocked
Oh
But marriage it's over
Literally unlocking my doors now blackmail time
Forget netflix and chill when xbox and shove it into your smashbox
I've never heard that terminology before
Oh, wait, wait, wait, let me get on the game so you can get my
Pie holes for adblock and don't tell them that you can do a lot with a piehole though
You can do quite a lot with piehole
Hmm
Mummy can I have a hug and a kiss to have a headache? Oh, I'm sorry. I've been really loud
Well, I'll give you headpats with a microphone because this microphone can't cover like can't hear a hug it. It doesn't work
um
Please tell me you got these yesterday. Don't read it out loud. Monk away. I'm opening up your cat box link. What am I about to see?
That's that's manga wink wink
Uh as he pulled apart the cheeks of
Hmm, I'll replace the girl's name with my name as he pulled apart the cheeks of strony's huge butt with his fingers
He plunged his tentacles as far as it could go and strony could feel him pouring his genetic material
Into the deepest depths of her body. Oh, yes, pour your genetic material into me. We fling
There's a text post monka
Monka was the text post then
Hmm
Hi, mom. I love you. I love you too. I wanted to check on you after that ring for it stream
You said your muscles were sore and I'd like to help you out. You wrote me rp
I want
To strip you down and lay you on the massage table
I'd get some oil and start with my neck on your back then slowly work my way down your thighs legs and feet
You could tell me that I missed the spot and raise your butt slightly waggling it wagging it waggling
Oh, okay. I don't think pours genetic material was bigger. Honestly
Okay, I can't read the rest of that but I've got the link open so I can read it once the ad stream in
Um, mommy. I'm so happy. I got to bark for you, but I was petrified by anxiety anxiety. Oh my god. No, am I killing you guys?
Am I killing you refling?
Unironically am I killing you? I feel like I'm giving you like so much stress just trying to play with me
I think I'm doing more damage than good. Mommy. I'm so happy I got to bark
I was petrified by anxiety that I don't normally get otherwise I would have barked better
Either way, it was so much fun. Hopefully next time I'll bark better. Oh, I'm killing you
I'm actually killing you. Welcome to internet select. No, no, no. I'm mommy. You're refling the milk and then begins
You could say you're killing us softly. Oh, no, I hope I don't get deducted by yandere cuttlefish
We just want to make sure we put on a good show
My heart was beating a bit fast. Oh, not at all. We're learning to get out of our shells
I'm I'm
It's more I'm scared of a being every order. I will
One at a time mommy drained in all the refunds. I felt really nervous during the Elden Ring stream snipe
Especially when I was afk. Oh, no, I'm not. Don't be scared. You basically fulfill needs. We don't get anywhere
I mean
As long as you're happy and thriving. That's the main thing
We talk big talk be a text but our voices can be so shy. Stop. You're so unwordable
This is adorable
Hmm
This is adorable. I was nervous as well. So
My little inklings you're so fucking cute. I want to
You're so badly right now
I want to fucking I want to like do those memes
Where it's like you're texting me like big game and all that and then I come over and you're so shy
You can hardly speak and I'm like, yeah, it's my time to talk
This is so fucking cute. I can't handle it
Ah, stop being so cute. I'm smiling so hard right now. My cheeks are sore my face cheeks
My face cheeks are sore
Oh
I'm
I'm so cute
Okay, let me refresh let me refresh
Mummy when's the doughnathon? I want to make sure I'm prepared beforehand. My birthday is the 10th of october
So I'm just doing my regular birthday, but then my doughnathon is going to be on the saturday
Um, I've still undecided. I'm going to decide next week what the deal is peo. Sorry if I sent this twice
I'm trying to figure out marshmallow. No, no, no, you're fine. Don't worry. Don't don't ever worry
If you've accidentally sent like a double marshmallow. It does not do anything. I promise I'm not like
This reefling is so inefficient. No, I am not like that
um
Just like naruto then. Oh, I've got the same birthday as naruto. Hold on
Let's find out let's find out. Oh, yeah, me and naruto. Oh, yeah, that's right. Me and naruto celebrating on a birthday
Hmm
Thank you for the stream mummy. I am more than welcome. Yeah, that's cool
The funny part is in real life is how it would actually go
Me just staring at you with my r word eyes on do you think I can get a toggle for that?
What would I what would our word eyes be? I don't know. I'm sure I could
Oh, no, are you?
For no particular reason
Uh, he's drawny. I kind of get nervous to talk as well, but I want to work on myself and get better. Yeah
Do reeflings move like cows when you milk them? No, you can run. You're like
Think like zombie noises but more human
I was hoping myself I'll practice in my bark so I could make you happy when I joined but then I frozen couldn't do it
When the moment came
Oh my god, wait, I never even asked that
Have any of you popped a tent will stream sniping be honest
Anonymous thank you for the tip wait you send send out marshmallow. You don't have to explode yourself in the stream
We howl
Oh
Maybe no way. Oh my god. Stop
Stop
You shouldn't reveal this information to me now. I'm to focus on trying to carry you to gas
Honestly though, I'm like really bad at this
Hi, mommy when you and she be went to up front to me earlier to ask me a bark
I tried my heart to see if my mic was picking up but nothing
Even though you tested it. Oh, I'm so sorry. I didn't pick up my embarrass and wanes. I'm sorry. Don't call is that what?
No, yes. Oh my god
To focus so there's real gamers and there's real gunner
This year of the linux desktop is finally here
To update those every day, but not today again
I normally am not shy, so I barked really loudly, but I realized my mic was often pretty sure my
Me
No
I'm so sorry
That's hilarious to think that you're like your neighbors are like what the fuck is going on through that wall
And you're just like
Yeah
We're all good gamers here exactly
Gaming comes first. I can't believe I have some real gamers in here shocking the video these mics
Since all the models have their own mascots and members the velar has some sort of mascot member
No, there's no symbolism
For velar like in a mascot. Nah
Uh
I considered it, but because
the
The logo has a microphone in it. I was like, just call it that
Hi, scrawny. I want to absolutely ruin your back
Honestly, wait, there's another shit post
Sudo, I'm deleting gnu and linux 10% 99% complete error true open source software is impeccable
The velar mascot is unity refling exactly
My neighbors have an obnoxious dog that barks at everything. I'm sure I'll be fine with a loud bark about one
And now I need to train yous to pant and once you know how to pan and bark
I have you wrapped around my little finger
My plan is almost complete the sucky goes vacuum cleaner
Let's go inking. Oh dang it. Oh dang it. That was my longest yet
But did you know the let's go gambling guy has an odd dang it merch?
How could we buy you one you want to buy me a hat? Why?
That seems so random in particular
Oh
Hi, scrawny. I think I'll buy a mic so I can say hi when I play games. I love you. I love you, too
You don't have to buy a microphone
I promise you don't have to buy a microphone
I'd rather you keep your money and spend on yourself something nice
All right, linux shit poster wrap it up wrap it up third time's your charm
I can pant for you anytime damn straight
Yeah, but the most important thing is
I leave you stream on audio playing over my speakers and have a nap it makes you enter my dream and I wake up
With a big tentacle and thinking my name is refling
I think since you always scream refling on stream, I get scolded a lot with the tunes like that or six
He is kind of scolding
You're the reflin that wants me to do an angry audio in my accent isn't that?
I said reflin. Yeah, I'm done. I'm gonna finish with you yet
Now refling what you mean
I hope my bark was sufficient for you. You joked about us being pre-trained, but that includes you too, doesn't it?
I had tears you
You want to train me more?
The hypno stream worked we're winning
Strani, I just had to my landlord visit me and raise my rent because he heard barking coming from my place instead
I had a pet
Next time I don't think how bark is loud. Okay, you win. Hold on. Hold on. You win
Let me open up my stream deck. You fucking win. That was good
That was good. I'll give you that one. You're getting a round of applause for that one
Hmm
Mom, I haven't popped the tent while playing with you yet
But I think it's more of a matter of being focused on the game
And if you really dedicate a moment to teasing it would definitely happen though. You give me a heart bone
Oh, that was so awesome
Sorry, I can't join until the end of my read-a-moment. Thank you for stream sniping. Have a good night rest well sleepyhead
She be just retweeted a
An art of you and I see the person also did an art of you and I see wait what?
Hold on a minute for no particular reason we're gonna pause
Uh and go on she views twitter alternate twitter
Oh
I have a pintas
Huh
I'm a pintas
I have a pintas
Oh my god, I fucking hate twitter hate and all this stuff. Oh my god, there's more
I'm fucking ramen asu. Oh my god
Why does it always hate stuff? This is why I freaking hate
Do I have a pintas is a question I never thought of yes. Oh my god, I need to retweet the like ace up
Oh my god, one of them has a ac has a binky
Oh, thank you for the call. I wouldn't have seen that. Okay, I'll go retweet the mother
I've never watched a vtuber let alone a streamer that was so vocal about wanting to bang their own fans
Wait, is that okay watching you has legit changed my brain and now I can't stop thinking about you are wording me
I've converted you
Yeah, are you getting it now? Are you getting the best part?
Are you are you understanding? I want your ink is this isn't going in
I think it's working
Oh, what's that you're used to fucking you're used to vtubers like
Fucking putting on an act and being like I hate my job. I hate doing anything remotely
Uh
Alternative and they hate it and did is there?
No, I'm fucking coming for your ink. It's main wait until in and in and tell me if I'm not passionate about my job then, huh
It's not even a fucking job. We are we inking?
Are we inking them in these trees?
Well, your birthday lines up with national walk to the park day. Maybe it was fate you become a puppy puppy vtuber arc when
I
One nice thing about power social relationships is that you can experience feelings that help for later
You ask them you ask them to bark and they give a half hearted and quite
Quiet extra bark. They are a bit shy and tentative
But do it anyway later these reeflings will find future lady reeflings and they ask them to bark
They'll be ready to do it and be able to flirt back and they'll be quite happy and proud you gave them the push
So keep asking the reeflings to bark
That's so cute. It's good for them. Oh, you're so fucking cute
Yeah, even if your bark is really tiny and cute and adorable. Don't worry. I can keep training
I
Train you harder. You're my responsibility for now. Okay
And then if you ever want to go don't worry, mommy understand
But for now you're under my leash
You're colored and leashed
The question was raised earlier about what flavors are here. Everyone says what I mean
So I think it's what I mean
Mmm
Mommy how much overtime should as reeflings there for the don't nothing
Literally no overtime. Please don't test maro because I don't think they're getting through also. Love you. Momelov
Well, I find that one
Can't read that one
I'll read the set. Hi strong. I sometimes wonder if you want to that's it not reading the rest
Rebar been custard here. Oh, yeah, someone said that we we we better bad
We have to work in the weekend from no, don't go over time 100 hours over time. No, you're gonna upset me
Read it in code. I cannot read that one in code
It literally has noted in it. I am no I can't read that in code
I didn't mean nothing
Wait, are you the watermelon? Are you the person that started all?
Are you the person like you're the first person to say that my hair is watermelon flavorant?
Wait, can you hear it?
It out. I just hit my fucking chin on the mic. If you heard that
Idiot, I'm like, I don't think you can hear it. She never don't make it make a noise. It's
It's not gonna make a noise. I can only tap it
Like that's the only way I can do it
You got two lollipops on your head. Are you seeing me?
Get it. Thank you. I don't I don't want to miss for the tip
I mean and you can give you are born
Then
Well mate, I'm not too familiar with Vtuber culture. Don't worry
Do people usually put their user names in marshmallows? No, they do not. So marshmallow is supposed to be anonymous
Um, and it's uncommon to
I wouldn't they definitely hardly ever get it
I don't know if it's frowned upon. Am I supposed to spank people if they do that?
I don't know
My heart flutters when I play with you. Um, and you compliment me. I can't get a tank because it's a depression med
Oh, I remember seeing a don't give up on those meds. By the way, um
They take a long time to take effect and they help. Um, I know it takes away your bone bone
Which is really a really bizarre thing to take away. But um, I wait. No, I already said that
Yeah, I already said that someone was like, oh, why is there not fast acting anti-depressants motherfucker?
That's called hardcore drugs. They're classified. Um, don't
Don't don't don't forget to take them because it takes a very long time for them to get into your system. Um
And if you stop or have to change doses, it becomes a fucking nightmare. Um
Cause I used to do research on depression medication and that shit's fucking hard. Uh, if you didn't know, depression and a
Narcotic
Uh drugs or they're currently trialling lsd for long-term depression right now. Uh, and it's having some interesting results
I am watching it. Um
For fuck's sake, how is this a linux shit poster?
How is this a linux shit poster? I'd just like to interject for a moment. What you're referring to is linux is in fact gnu linux or
As I've recently taken to call it gnu plus linux linux. It's not an operating system in itself
Right, wrap it up linux boy. Wrap it up
Wrap it up. Hmm
Oh
I general a base interjector. That's a coffee pasta. Well, better wrap it up
um
Hi, stormy. I'm feeling very gnu today
You
Enjoy your gnu session then ha ha I can't read that one up, but you know what but yeah
First Ronnie wait, what did you meet?
What did you do?
We should watch the batman movies. I've not seen that
What a melon. I fucking love watermelon. You know how much I love watermelon mean
I love it so much
I don't know why people hate it. Am I going great? Wait, what is the lore?
Is there like a hidden lore about it that I don't know because
I love what a melon
What a melon it's just such a good meme
I like it as long as I'm good feature for memes like came out. I just like
I think
Wait, why are you sweating? Wait, is there a thing behind it that I don't know? Is it not just literally her going watermelon?
Yeah, the smug. Yeah, the smugness
Hey
What am I has publicly recognized it so she thinks it's funny the face gets me
It's like a painting. There is a watermelon game somewhere suica
Suica
Oh, I got a code
Hello my little pops. Thanks for always being a good girl. Thank you
Fine art. There's a 3d version of suica now with whole life pieces of the fruit
And the streusel and smug ore amongst them
Holy shit, how long have I been yapping for? Did we don't finish like 40 minutes ago?
A
Mummy can you bark and give us a kiss?
I've heard
Oh, wait, sorry. You said kiss not time other one
Hey
Yappler honestly something like that
Time flies you with the one you love
Long enough it's about time to go back to work. Uh, we have to go back to work
You should play a game called thank goodness. You are here. It's a funny game
Thank goodness you are here everyone has that panting out of reflex. Good fuck
Shit you're not in there
Does pitch an attempt by hearing your voice can't just my voice alone that is some Pavlovian
a
Pavlov
Hi, strongy you making a fuss over the reeflings being shy was very stimulating wink wink
I don't know why the cuter you are the more are wordable you've become so when you tell me you're shy. I'm like
Oh, shall I ability reefling here? I heard my back over the weekend. Oh, no
The stream today I should be back to work tomorrow. Are you gonna be are you well enough to go back to work if you hurt yourself?
Please be careful with your back your knees your body. Please be careful
Thank you lonely glizzy. What a fucking name lonely hotdog. Um, thank you. Hey lonely glizzy
Please make sure you stretch gently and all of that. Um, that goes for all your reeflings
I need you flexible for what? I love Pavlov. Why do I get hard when you use the dog clicker?
I want to get a clicker so badly
I'm allowed to get a clicker and then we can start doing that
Momolo voice activated pintas your pintas has been activated all your cum are below
All your ink are belong to us
Oh
Fuck okay, okay. I'll write down clicker
I got on my little piece of paper. Please get one. Okay. Sorry. I'm so good. I want no I said ink
What do you mean voice activated pintas? It wakes up when I show up
Hmm
Hi, scrawny is the pilot single. Oh, you like the you like the pilot of this mecca, huh?
Would she like to be my girlfriend? Thanks for passing on the message. Oh, yeah
As long as you're a certified reefling
And you know how you're certified me right now
Those eggs are worth it. Do you like that? We beg for you to bark or would you rather have us all clap those cheeks and make you bark without?
contraint
It was that meant to be constrained
I'm afraid my English is a bit poor. You see I come from this foreign country called Scotland
Was that supposed to be constrained? I think I was supposed to be constrained. Thank you, Anand
Anonymous with the tip
See some people are like, uh, I wish I wish steamer was always one way or another
Fucking switches the best of both worlds. Like holy fuck. I'll get to put the collar on you. You get to put the collar on me
Blake, I don't know what's going on. I don't know what the problem is. Can you pan for like a good puppy before you go?
I might
scrawny cut was my favorite
Is Brian's volume low? Oh, it might be
I
Like thinking about a five three fifty kilogram mummy trying to pin me down
Fuck you. My legs are stronger than my upper body. I can pin you down. I can leg lock you
I can do a lot with my thighs and my legs. Okay
I can make it happen
I assure you I have enough strength in my legs to make up for whatever the rest of my body that can't make up, okay
Thunder says literally we're gonna do a fruit crush and stream
Even if I'm mainly is being in sometimes
Prove it. Oh, no, we're gonna do a fruit crush and stream
I'm gonna do a stream where I crush fruit in between my thighs. It's gonna be a milestone though
So it's not anytime soon. But yeah
All of the masses and her legs and her butt. I think it's because I ride a bike
I don't know how to drive
So I ride a bike and I think that's why I've been very blessed
Mummy making wine stepping on them grapes with her feet. Oh, no, I wouldn't want to hurt you
I would be stunned locked by nervousness
Actually, yeah, would I even have to like lock you?
If you'd be so scared to do anything with me really
Hmm
I was gonna say I'm just gonna say I want a slurpy glorpy session audio with scrawny. That's such a good word slurpy glorpy
um
Are you like boa? Yeah
My penis is clap activated when mommy claps all the time
Oh, that's so cute
The most powerful lip looks are the ones in the mind
Average reflund would just pass it barking while inking and panting after inking
I would be paralyzed by the forwardness. So no, you you wouldn't even have to try
Strongly must be the type of girl who likes guys that can't look women in the eye. Yeah
Stereotypical nerdy guy gets bullied by the popular girl
I'm not a fucking popular girl. Don't put me in that ranking
I got fucking bullied by the the in quotation marks popular girl
We fucking hate high school in these fucking streets. Thank you grimmed by failure
um
Uh, I think he's cute. I think because um, like genuine switch
I think I don't mind either way if you were forthcoming or if I was the one who was forthcoming
Then company then what the fuck is company?
What did I even mix that word with come?
Forthcoming oh coming. Okay, got it. Sorry
No, wait, you're a hundredth of popular girls. You just come
I literally dropped out of high school because I had no friends
so
Yeah, I got I got excluded
Uh by my established friend group and then I left and then I don't have a high school education
I never finished high school
Because I had no friends
Um
You what? Yeah, I'm not high school educated. I dropped out
I had no friends and I was um, I developed like social anxiety and all that
I don't have social anxiety anymore. Hey, I just have general the one that sticks about me unfortunately, but
um
Yeah, like have I not told this it's a bit depressing. This is probably why I've not said it
I had a really
Really bad time at high school, which led me to be in housebound for two years and I developed very extreme a bomb
Um, but thankfully I don't have like social a bomb at all. Like I'm very confident. I love I love socializing
I think like to make up for like the time I couldn't basically
um
That's why like I'm good at well good quotation marks. That's why I'm into video games because you know
Video game interactions a lot different than like real life type stuff. Um
But yeah, that's why I'm not high school educated and I've never finished high school. I left
um
Johnny's got no gcs. He's
Hey
Um
I'm so really to hear things got better. Oh, yeah, things got better. Like I just have the regular born anxiety, you know
I have the one that's like don't leave the house
And the world is scary and I'm like, okay
That's really fucking boring to deal with. I hate it's the boring one. It's the resident sleeper one
Hmm
Sorry to hear that. I didn't hear that. I didn't want to bring it. No, no, I don't mean talking about it
I don't I don't like talking about sad subjects in general. Um
But yeah, I uh, yeah, that's the lord like I don't know
Maybe you're like, oh shoneys too much into internet culture something's going on and it was like I never went
I was saying, you know party drink all that kind of thing never had none of that
None of it all just video games video games. Um
Like when I say that my parents are really understanding about me playing video games
Um, obviously that extended into time where I should have been in education
But they knew that I was fucked up from it and they didn't know what to do with me
So they just let me play video games. Um, and it worked out in the end. I mean, holy shit mom and dad
I'm so playing video games. Um, so yeah, that's why I always say like mom and dad are the best and all of that
Nothing you need that education anyway
Literally like I don't know how it worked out because everything should have gone wrong
but it worked out in the end and um
the way I got over my um
The major like social anxiety was um, um, my job as a waitress
My job's really really helped me all the jobs that I've had in the past like really really helped me be myself and
realize that like
Ken what the world is scary, but I can't live my life in between four walls type thing
um
Yeah
You put in the work even you see us work. I've never seen the appeal of going to parties
I don't and I'm I don't if you get has anyone been to a party
I think it's for socializing and just telling funny stories and that right
And but people get a bit drunk and then sometimes they make out
And then sometimes they find a pair of her at the party that's in the cent play
get her
And I avoided the some parties. Have you been to
Becks parties
They make it
Parties are the worst. Yeah, it's just to meet new people
Damn
All of you girls have crazy lore
Minds the loner I could have been a
I can't say that uh, especially not with what's happened really recently. Um
Yeah, my lore is the loner
Basically, I don't know what everyone else is. I don't know what the girls have said their lore is but my my lore is the loner
That's why you haven't kept to ink for a voice to ink for the personality to ink for veiny hands to ink
Oh, you like my veiny hands really say a voice to ink for oh, yeah
Have a lot to ink for and in my pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop
Thank you
for the tip
I've been at parties. There's just some friends my first job I had
It was cursed as it helped me a lot in some ways to get better
Place on
very
Sorry, that's a lot of words
Too bad. I'm trying my best to read them. I guess I have been a part lately. It was like all after I graduated though
I've been a one you've been a beg
party
Now hold on a minute. Pull up the receipt. Pull up the notes. What happened?
What happens? It's not as crazy as you think and also it's way quieter than most parties. What happens?
I hurt myself seven years ago when I was new to construction back pain reflex last week
We were more busy than usual. So lots of heavy lifting that caused it
Also, since I graduated I've also become more socially anxious
Oh, I thought it would get better because like if you're in the workplace and that I found it easier to actually
I fucking hated the high school environment. I absolutely hated it
And then once I realized the world isn't like high school, then it got better
Lonely glizzy. Thank you for the tip. I hope your back is better. Holy fuck, please
You're not lifting with your back, right? You're lifting with your knees
Yeah
Right, I'm pretty sure it's your knees. You're the last 12
Stronger you're the sexy woman I've ever known everything about you makes me want to ink. Oh, yeah
Imagine uh, so I'm writing a meta audio. You approach the loner girl. Let's go
And it turns out she's a freak and she reads shoulder
Sorry, that was a bit terrible
Ah
I'm exposing myself cut the stream cut the stream. I'm exposing myself, right? I'm gonna redirect into um
I'm gonna redirect into a zero who is coming up. I'm coming up
To let the world know
What is this rude them?
Shazer is done for the week. Wait, what?
Her streams aren't up
I'll guess the streams are not uh, okay, I guess we'll redirect into
See
We've got to let the world know that she's playing wild arms alter codef party retro gaming on the ps
Um, that is today, right?
It's not today. Oh
All right, man
Uh serenity redirected into us so we'll redirect back into serenity as there's no members. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. She can
Right, we'll redirect into serenity
Yeah, I could beat my record to ink and that you can get empty from inking it hurts, but well worth it
Oh
How many thank you anonama for the tip
Honestly, I'm glad to see him people that suffered in school are v-troopers
I honestly think people can tell when a v-trooper isn't one of us in terms of like
If I ever saw a girl like you in high school, you would have fit right in with me and my circle of friends
I'll be the nerdy boy to your edgy got girl gamer. Yeah. Oh my god. Yeah
Because I was so dark and mysterious, but really I was just
I hated my life. I hated it
I hate
Thank you groomed by Vila grooms your heart
Okay
um, I'm gonna redirect into serenity and then I'm gonna go do my
My shorts and then I'm gonna hopefully take a few
I was the best party reflim it was quiet and preveted
Uh
Uh-huh frisky with one gal, but she didn't want go beyond finger
Okay, okay. The interaction was talking with another lad in the hot tub about games
I suppose they must have to vet you or else
BTDs
No one wants those
Wow, thank you anonama for the tip
Wow
I
Really cook I was 14 when I hurt myself. Wait, you're working on a job say a 14
Wait, are did I misunderstand the context? I wouldn't say
I wouldn't it was new to construction
Fucking nice child labor. Hold on a minute. The child the children might yearn for the mains for that 14
Ash on the ash on
I'm chilling with bro in the hot tub three tentacles apart because I'm not gonna hate you. That's a vain reason
child labor
If I knew you in house, so you'd be nervous to talk to you
I was the girl that used to get asked out
And uh, actually happened in primary school where they ask you out as a joke like no one. No, I don't want to actually
Go stronti
I'm the primary skill and I was like, I see
Like different from people because I'm so ghostly pale. Anyway enough doing I promise you life is good
Life is good. I got my reflins. I almost just called you your alternative name there. Holy shit
I almost said the r.a
Version of your name. Oh my god. That was so close, right
I'm gonna redirect you into serenity
Stop being so cute. It makes you and when you're cute it genuinely and wholeheartedly makes me want to
Okay
Stop being so cute, right
Sorry to cut it so short, but I love you lots. I will see you tomorrow
For I'm gonna very quickly check what we're doing tomorrow
Uh, we are playing in the slime rancher
Right, I've never actually played slime rancher before so I'm gonna role play it as uh
Me capture you in the slimes. You're the slimes. I need capture all my reflins. Well, okay
Hey, we'll play slime rancher too for the first time. I'll see you have fun. It is or no
I'm not sure and then uh, there's a membership
Uh, thank you so so much for the barrels of laugh loads of fun loads of kisses
I'll give you a kiss for every stream. Snape okay. You ready?
Um
And then two extra bonus kisses because we've played two
campaign maps, okay
Um, I love you. Please hydrate and stretch or go to sleep or get busy
And the wise words of the coconut from elden ring
Let's get to it
Love you reef and I'll see you tomorrow. Okay. You look after yourself
I know thank you
See you tomorrow
Thank you for stream sniping and lurking another thing thing. I don't want to go yet
I still got my collar on I don't want to go. I don't want I don't want to go. I want master to stay with me
I have to work if I do these shorts then
And then I can move on to the next thing which is more handsome mom. I don't want to go
Okay
I see you tomorrow
I see you tomorrow on slime ranchers too, which I've never played before but it's gonna be fun
because
Hello
Congrats on 268. Yay. Thank you. I have so much. I have 20 ASMR videos in there
Imagine going outside and forget to take your collar off
I
Has my fucking name on it as well strongy undeniable goth spotted at fucking willies fucking get
Okay, I go I go for real this time. I promise I go for real real
Say hi to serenity as always when I redirect into someone outside of yellow
They are much more tame than we are I repeat we are much more tame than we are okay
um
Okay, I see tomorrow
For all the slime ranching
Sucking your face off when I do it that hard
Okay, say say hi to serenity and be respectful. Thank you. We fun to see tomorrow
And then we'll plan life or death stream snake by the end of this month. Okay